COMMUNICATIONS [inaudible]
I HAVE.
WE ARE GONNA START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE.
OF THE COMMITTEE TO BEGIN HEAR
TESTIMONY AND FILLS.
I WANT ANNOUNCED FOR THE BENEFIT
OF THE PUBLIC.
THAT ITEMS FIVE AND SEVEN BOTH
SB TEN SEVENTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER PATTERSON.
AND SB FIFTEEN THIRTEEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN.
HAVE BEEN HELD IN COMMITTEE NOW
I'M JUST JOKING.
THAT THEY'VE BEEN THE THEY'VE
BEEN MOVED TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR -- ITEMS FIVE AND SEVEN
NO NO I'M SORRY.
HELLO I TO ME SORRY ABOUT THAT.
OKAY SO WE WILL BEGIN WITH --
ITEM NUMBER ONE A. B. FIVE
TWENTY THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
IRWIN WELCOME GOOD MORNING.
MORNING CHAIR HUESO AND SENATORS
I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT TO AB
FIVE TWO THREE THIS MORNING THIS
BILL IS IN RESPONSE TO TROUBLING
INVESTIGATIVE JOURNALISM THAT
UNCOVERED THE PRACTICE OF
SELLING TELECOMMUNICATIONS --
INFORMATION -- REAL TIME -- DATA
LOCATION OF THE OF
TELECOMMUNICATIONS COMPANIES
SELLING REAL TIME INFORMATION
ABOUT THEIR SUBSCRIBERS REAL
TIME DATA INFORMATION.
THIS INFORMATION WAS AND PACKAGE
AND RESOLD BY MIDDLEMAN TO
ANYONE WILLING TO PAY USUALLY
BOUNTY HUNTERS.
AND OTHERS WITH AN INTERESTED IN
FINDING.
OR STOCKING INDIVIDUALS I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR HELPING TO BETTER
REFINE THE BILL THROUGH
AMENDMENTS THAT I WILL BE TAKING
AS THE BILL MOVES -- FROM THIS
COMMITTEE AND HEADS TO JUDICIARY.
COPIES OF THE AMENDMENT MOCK UPS
ARE BEING MADE AVAILABLE FROM
THE COMMITTEE STAFF.
AND SINCE OF YOU HAVEN'T SEEN
THEM YET I WOULD LIKE TO BRIEFLY
TALK ABOUT THESE AMENDMENTS
THESE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
THEY WOULD SUBSTITUTE THE
CURRENT LANGUAGE OF THE BILL AND
DO THE FOLLOWING PROHIBIT A
WIRELESS TELECOM PROVIDER OR ANY
DIRECT OR INDIRECT AFFILIATE OF
A PROVIDER FROM DISCLOSING CELL
SITE LOCATION INFORMATION TO ANY
PARTY.
WITHOUT FIRST OBTAINING THE
SUBSCRIBERS EXPRESS CONSENT.
PROVIDE EXCEPTIONS TO THIS
DISCLOSURE SOLELY FOR NINE ONE
ONE PURPOSES AND PURSUANT TO A
WARRANT.
SPECIFIED THAT THE EXPRESSED
CONSENT MUST BE OFTEN AND
CLEARLY IDENTIFIED THE PARTIES
TO WHOM THE INFORMATION WILL BE
DISCLOSED IN THE CUSTOMER'S
RIGHT TO REVOKE CONSENT AT ANY
TIME.
ESTABLISH A DUTY FOR TELECOMS TO
COMPLY WITH THE REVOCATION OF
ITS CONSENT.
AND CLARIFY THAT DELIBERATE
VIOLATIONS OF THE PROHIBITION ON
DISCLOSURE ARE GROUNDS FOR A
CIVIL.
SUIT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
NOTE.
THAT UNDER THE CURRENT LAW THIS
SAME LOCATION INFORMATION IS
AVAILABLE ONLY TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT WITH A SEARCH
WARRANT.
SO THAT'S OF BOUNTY HUNTERS ARE
ABLE TO GET THIS INFORMATION FOR
A SMALL FEE.
IS -- ABSOLUTELY WRONG.
A AND AND IT DOES SHOW HOW
SENSITIVE THIS INFORMATION IS
THAT'S FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT THEY
NEED A WARRANT WITH AB FIVE TWO
THREE CALIFORNIA'S WILL BE ABLE
TO KEEP THEIR REAL TIME LOCATION
OF THEIR CELL PHONES PROTECTED
AND OUT OF THE HANDS OF
STRANGERS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND DO WE HAVE
TESTIMONY.
ON THIS BILL ANYBODY IN PUBLIC
WISH TO SPEAK IN FAVOR.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS DEEP CARL
SOBRE SI TI A THE WIRELESS
ASSOCIATION WE'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL MONTHS -- AT ONE TO GIVE
A LITTLE BIT OF BACKGROUND ON ON
ON WHAT HAPPENED -- THE WIRELESS
INDUSTRY IN ORDER TO PROVIDE
THINGS LIKE ROADSIDE ASSISTANCE --
FIRST ALERT AND THOSE SORTS OF
BENEFICIAL CONSUMER SERVICES --
PROVIDED.
LOCATION INFORMATION AND THEIR
OPINION IT WAS COMMITTEE
CUSTOMERS AT OPTED IN TO THE USE
OF THE INFORMATION FOR THAT SORT
TO A DATA AGGREGATOR.
BECAUSE IT WAS A MORE EFFICIENT
WAY TO PROVIDE THAT INFORMATION
OUT TO THE VARIOUS ROADSIDE
ASSISTANCE AND OTHER OTHER
GROUPS -- WITHOUT THEIR CONSENT --
INTO THEIR DISMAY -- THE
AGGREGATORS USE THE INFORMATION
IN WAYS THAT HAD NOT BEEN
AUTHORIZED BY THE WIRELESS
COMPANIES THE WIRELESS COMPANIES
EAST PROVIDING INFORMATION TO
THOSE AGGREGATORS.
HAVE STOPPED THAT -- AND IT ALSO
WHEN THAT WAY HAVE STOPPED
ACTUALLY PROVIDING INFORMATION
TO THAT ROADSIDE ASSISTANCE AND
SOME OF THOSE OTHER SO I WE
THINK THAT THERE'S A POTENTIAL
NEGATIVE HERE -- IN WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR WE UNDERSTAND THAT
HER ISSUE WAS DEALING WITH.
AND YOUR LOCATION INFORMATION WE
HAVE AGREED -- TO DEAL TO
PROVIDE OPT IN. TO YOUR LOCATION
INFORMATION.
ARE WE PROVIDED -- WE THOUGHT
REASONABLE STRAIGHT FORD
AMENDMENTS THAT PROHIBITS SALE
TO THIRD PARTIES -- AND EVEN
INSURANCE CUSTOMERS WHO ARE
HARMED -- CAN BRING SUIT IN
STATE COURT UNFORTUNATELY --
THIS LATEST SET OF AMENDMENTS
WHICH WE ONLY SAW YESTERDAY AT
NOON SO WE HAVEN'T EVEN HAD
TWENTY FOUR HOURS TO TAKE A LOOK
AT IT.
GO WELL BEYOND WHAT WE HAD HOPED
AND AND HAD BEEN DISCUSSING WITH
THE AUTHOR WE WANT TO CONTINUE
TO WORK ON IT WE KNOW GOES OVER
THE JUDICIARY -- AND IT'S A
PRIVACY ISSUE SO -- DO JUDICIARY
IS QUITE ACTIVE -- ON THOSE
ISSUES -- BUT WE PLAN TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR --
IN THE COMMITTEE -- BUT AT THIS
POINT THESE CONCERNS ARE ARE
VERY SIGNIFICANT AND AS WE GO
FURTHER WILL CONTINUE OUR
DISCUSSION BUT FOR NOW WE MUST
OPPOSE.
VERY WELL MEMBERS.
ANYONE OKAY YOU WANT MY CLOSING
COMMENTS OF AYE I JUST WANT TO
POINT BACK TO THE STORY THAT WAS
IN THE NEW YORK TIMES -- WAS
PROBABLY SIX MONTHS AGO WHERE
ARE A PERSON IN NEW YORK WAS --
ABLE TO COMPLETELY OF FIND EVERY
STEP THAT THEY HAD TAKEN
EVERYWHERE THAT THEY HAD GONE
AND BECAUSE THIS NFORMATION WAS
BEING -- RESOLD TO DATA BROKERS
REAL TIME INFORMATION IS
EXTREMELY SENSITIVE AND IT NEEDS
THE ABSOLUTE HIGHEST LEVEL OF
PROTECTION AND WITH THIS BILL WE
WILL MAKE SURE THAT CALIFORNIANS --
TO RECEIVE THAT PROTECTION.
THAT IS AMAZING TO KNOW THAT WAS
HAPPENING.
BUT THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONTINUED
COMMITMENT. TO TO SECURITY AND
TO PROTECTING PEOPLE'S
IDENTITIES.
AND WILL -- MOVE THE BILL WHEN
WE HAVE A FOUR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH CHAIR AND SENATORS
[inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LIVING.
ITEM NUMBER TWO AB.
SIX SIXTY GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR HOW ARIA.
GOOD GOOD GOOD MORNING GOOD
THANK YOU GLAD TO BE HERE -- I
JUST WANT TO SAY THAT I
APPRECIATE THE THE BILL ANALYSIS
BY THE COMMITTEE STAFF AND I'M
HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS THAT WAS REALLY GREAT
WORK AND I'M GRATEFUL AND
APPRECIATIVE OF IT THANKS.
I EIGHTY SIX HE DIRECTS THE
ENERGY COMMISSION TO CONSIDER
MORE THAN DOUBLING THE SOLAR
REFLECTANCE REQUIREMENT FOR
STEEP ROOFS ON EXISTING
RESIDENTIAL BUILDINGS
INAPPROPRIATE CLIMATE ZONES BY.
TWENTY THIRTY IF THAT IS COST
EFFECTIVE.
ENERGY EFFICIENT PERSON ON A
SCHOOL REUSS THESE ROOFS ARE
DESIGNED REFLECT SUNLIGHT ABSORB
LESS HEAT.
AND AND IN FACT DECREASE -- THE
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE AND
AND THAT THE CREATION HEAT
ISLANDS IN VERY HOT PLACES --
WRIST LAST ABOUT TWENTY YEARS
AND SO WE COULD BE ON A CYCLE
FOR REDUCING HEAT ISLANDS AND
AND INCREASING EFFECTIVENESS
VERY QUICKLY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WITH ME.
TODAY IS RUNNING LEVINSON FROM
THE LAWRENCE BERKELEY NATIONAL
LABORATORY.
YES GOOD MORNING THANK YOU --
I'M RENTAL IN CINEMA STAFF
SCIENTIST AT LAWRENCE BERKELEY
NATIONAL LABORATORY.
HOWEVERTHE VIEWS PRESENTED HERE
ARE MINE IS AN EXPERT AND ARE
NOT INTENDED TO REFLECT ANY
POSITION OF LAWRENCE BERKELEY
NATIONAL LABORATORY AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA OR THE
DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY
RESIDENTIAL COOL REQUIREMENTS OF
ALL TOO LITTLE SINCE THEY WERE
INTRODUCED IN CALIFORNIA'S
BUILDING ENERGY EFFICIENCY
STANDARDS OVER A DECADE AGO.
TITLE TWENTY FOUR PART SIX
PRESCRIBE SCHOOL ROUTES FOR
HOMES IN ONLY SIX OF THE STATE'S
SIXTEEN CLIMATE ZONES BECAUSE
THE ORIGINAL COST BENEFIT
ANALYSIS.
THAT WE HAD LBNL PERFORMED FOR
THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHT TITLE
TWENTY FOUR CODE CYCLE INCLUDED
TWO KEY ASSUMPTIONS.
FIRST IT MODELED NEW HOMES OF
WELL INSULATED ROOFS RATHER THAN
EXISTING HOMES OF POORLY
INSULATED ROOFS.
CORPS OF PRODUCTS ARE MOST
EFFECTIVEWHEN ROOF SEVERAL
INSULATION.
SECOND IT MODEL LOWER
PERFORMANCE RESIDENTIAL COOL
ROOF PRODUCTS WITH AN AGE SOUL
REFLECTANCE OF ZERO POINT.
TWO ZERO RATHER THAN HIGHER
PERFORMANCE RESIDENTIAL PRODUCTS
WITH AN H. REFLECTANCE TWICE
THAT IS ZERO POINT.
FOUR ZERO OR PERFORMANCE
RESIDENTIAL COOL ROOF IS NO COR
THAN A TYPICAL COMMERCIAL
BUILDING GRAY ROOF THEY HAVE THE
SAME AGE SOUL REFLECTANCE.
AND IS MUCH WARMER THAN A
TYPICAL COMMERCIAL BUILDING
WHITE ROOF AGE OR FIGHT IS ABOUT
ZERO POINT.
SIX ZERO A RECENT STUDY
PUBLISHED BY LBNL PUBLISHED IN
THE PEER REVIEWED JOURNAL ENERGY
AND BUILDING FOUND THAT OUR
EARLIER ANALYSIS SUBSTANTIALLY
UNDERESTIMATED.
THE POTENTIAL BENEFITS OF COOL
ROOF RETROFITS FOR HOMEOWNERS
TENANTS AND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
KEY POINTS ABOUT 90% OF THE
RESIDENTIAL ROOF SURFACING
MATERIAL SOLD IN CALIFORNIA IS
INSTALLED ON EXISTING HOMES.
THE BENEFIT OF A COOL RIFF
PRODUCT UNDER EXISTING HOME ITS
ANNUAL COOLING SAVINGS MINUS THE
ANNUAL HEATING PENALTY IS ABOUT
TWO TO FOUR TIMES THAT OF THE
SAME PRODUCT ON A NEW HOME.
ALSO THE BENEFIT OF HIGHER
PERFORMANCE COOL ROOF PRODUCT IS
ABOUT THREE TIMES THAT OF A
LOWER PERFORMANCE SCORES
PRODUCTS. TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
CALIFORNIA'S STATEWIDE UTILITY
CODES AND STANDARDS PROGRAM
STUDY FOUND COMPARABLE PRICES
FOR HIGHER PERFORMANCE AND LOWER
PERFORMANCE RESIDENTIAL COOL
RIFF PRODUCTS.
AND ALSO REPORTED MEDICAL
BENEFITS TO COOL ROOFS INCLUDING
URBAN HEAT ISLAND MEDICATION
GLOBAL COOLING BETTER AIR
QUALITY AND IMPROVED HUMAN
HEALTH AND COMFORT.
FINALLY CONSIDERATION OVER THE
NEXT TWELVE YEARS FOR TRAINING --
CODE CYCLES OF TITLE. TWENTY
FOUR TO RAISING PRODUCT
PERFORMANCE REQUIREMENTS FOR
RESIDENTIAL COOL REFRESHER FITS
AND EXPANDING THE RANGE OF
CLIMATES OWNS TO WHICH THESE
REQUIREMENTS APPLY.
COULD SUBSTANTIALLY BOOST TO
COOL ROOF ENERGY COST SAVINGS
ENJOYED BY HOMEOWNERS ATTENDANCE
AND HELP CALIFORNIA MEET ITS SB
THREE THIRTY GOAL OF DOUBLING
ENERGY EFFICIENCY SAVINGS BY.
TWENTY THREE THANKS.
GENERALLY I MEAN WORLD.
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT CORPS OF
TECHNOLOGY OTHER THAN PAINTING
THE ROOF WHITE OR HAVING A LIGHT
COLOR ROOF?
AND HAVING THE VENTING WHAT ELSE
ARE YOU.
IN THIS CASE IS PRIMARILY WE
CALL COOL COLOR TECHNOLOGY HALF
OF SUNLIGHT IS INVISIBLE SO FOR
DECADES.
ROUTING PRODUCTS HAVE BEEN SOLD
THAT ARE MORE REFLECTIVE THAN
YOUR I WOULD.
PERCEIVE BECAUSE THEY DO A GOOD
JOB OF REFLECTING THE INVISIBLE
HALF OF SUNLIGHT.
IN FACT AN ORDINARY RED CLAY
TILE ROOF JUST AS AN EXAMPLE IS
ONE OF THOSE IT REFLECTS ONLY
ABOUT 20% OF VISIBLE LIGHT.
BUT ABOUT A 40% OF SUNLIGHT
BECAUSE IT'S REFLECTING A LOT OF
THE INVISIBLE SOME LIGHT THAT
STRIKES THE ROOF.
AND THAT'S TRUE OF MANY OTHER
COLORS.
TO SO IT'S READ A IF YOU HAVE A
BLACK ROOF I IMAGINE THAT'S
PROBABLY THE WORST.
AN ORDINARY BLACK ROOF.
OKAY ACTUALLY ON THE GOOD SIDE
WE GO HERE'S YEAH WE WE HAVE
SHOWN.
WE WE ACTUALLY CAN THEN BRING
OUT THE SAMPLES HERE BUT YOU CAN
MAKE A BLACK ROOF THAT REFLECTS
40% OF SUNLIGHT AND THE REASON
IS.
THE COLOR DOESN'T AFFECT ITS
ABILITY TO REFLECT THE INVISIBLE
SUNLIGHT AND OVER HALF OF THE
SUNLIGHT IS INVISIBLE THEY'RE
ACTUALLY PRODUCTS OUT THERE THAT
ARE BLACK AND WOULD MEET THIS
REQUIREMENT.
NOW OF COURSE NOT PROMOTING THE
USE OF BLACK ROOTS BUT HELL HELL
COLORS ARE AVAILABLE I'M ASKING
BECAUSE SO HOW CAN I MAKE MY
LIKE ROOF MORE REFLECTIVE.
THE BEST MOVE IS WHEN YOU ARE
IT'S TIME TO REPLACE THE ROOF
THAT'S WHEN YOU WANT TO CHOOSE A
COOL ROOFING PRODUCT BECAUSE
THAT WAY THERE'S NO ADDITIONAL
LABOR OR MATERIAL EXPENSE. FOR
MOST PRODUCTS THE COLOR IN THE
REFLECTANCE OF THE ROOFING
MATERIAL DON'T AFFECT THE PRICE
AND MOST ROOFS ARE PLACED ON
HOMES ABOUT EVERY TWENTY YEARS
THAT MEANS 5% OF THE ROOFING
STOCK IS TURNING OVER EACH YEAR.
JUST BECAUSE IT'S REACHED END OF
SERVICE LIFE AND THERE'S YOUR
OPPORTUNITY.
THANK YOU -- BE IN TWENTY YEARS
I GUESS BUT BUT ANYWAY THANK YOU
FOR THE FREE CONSULTATION --
ANYONE IN THE PUBLIC WE ALREADY
WENT THROUGH THIS MEMBERS.
WHAT WHAT IS THE COST OF THIS
OVER -- A CURRENT.
THE OUT NON REFLECTIVE ROUGH
SURE -- SO IS STUDY WAS SENT AS
A MENTION IN -- TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN FOR THE STATE AND WANTED
FOUND IS THAT. FOR MATERIALS
OTHER THAN ASPHALT SHINGLES FOR
EXAMPLE CLAY TILE CONCRETE TILE
METAL THERE IS NO COST PREMIUM.
SO THE COLOR IN THE REFLECTANCE
FOR THOSE TYPES OF BIRDS HAD NO
EFFECT ON THE PRICE.
AND FOR A ASPHALT SHINGLES WHICH
ARE QUITE COMMON THEY FOUND A
STRONG OVERLAP BETWEEN THE
PRICES OF THE ROOFS THAT ARE
REQUIRED BY TODAY'S BUILDING
CODES LOWER PERFORMANCE SCHOOL
ROOFS.
AND HIGHER PERFORMANCE COOL
RIFFS OF THE TYPE THAT I'M
SPEAKING.
SO IN MANY CASES THERE IS NO
DIFFERENCE IN PRICE IN SOME
CASES THERE IS A DIFFERENCE IN
PRICE.
I WOULD ALSO MENTION THOUGH THAT
THERE ARE SUBSTANTIAL ENERGY
COST SAVINGS PROVIDED BY GOING
TO THE COOL ROOF -- OVER THE
LIFETIME OF THE ROOF THE SAVINGS
OF A PRESENT VALUE OF ABOUT
FIFTY CENTS TO A DOLLAR PER
SQUARE FOOT.
SO EVEN IF YOU HAD A COST
PREMIUM OF THAT NATURE IT WOULD
BE PAID BACK BY THE ENERGY
SAVINGS.
AND I THINK AN IMPORTANT POINT
TO MAKE IS THAT COST
EFFECTIVENESS ISN'T A COMPONENT
OF THE BILL.
WE HAVE OPPOSITION LIKE TO SPEAK
ON THE BILL HE COULD COME
FORWARD [inaudible]
HEY HI.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS --
MY NAME IS READ HITCHCOCK I
SERVICE EXECUTIVE VICE PRESIDENT
OF THE ASPHALT ROOFING
MANUFACTURERS ASSOCIATION.
ADDITIONALLY I'M HERE BEFORE YOU
TODAY REPRESENTING NOT ONLY MY
ORGANIZATION BUT A COALITION
THAT INCLUDES APPROXIMATELY 90%
OF MANUFACTURES A ROOFING
MATERIALS.
INCLUDING CONCRETE AND CLAY TILE
INCLUDING SENIOR SHAKING
SHINGLES -- THOSE MATERIALS
AVAILABLE FOR LOW RISE
RESIDENTIAL STRUCTURES IN
CALIFORNIA THE RAW MATERIAL IN
EXCESS RE SUPPLIERS INSULATION
MANUFACTURERS DISTRIBUTORS AS
WELL AS THE CONTRACTOR BASED
INSTALLS WHICH MATERIALS.
OUR COALITION AS OPPOSED AB --
SIX SIXTY WHICH IS -- IN ITS
CURRENT FORM-- TAKES THE
SURFACE REFLECTANCE OF THE ROOF
FROM 2420% IN THE CURRENT
STANDARD 2405%.
IN THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY THIRTY
ONE STANDARD BUT ALSO PRESCRIBES
EXPANDING THE RANGE OF CLIMATE
ZONES WITHIN CALIFORNIA. TO
WHICH THESE REQUIREMENTS WOULD
APPLY.
AS A FRAME OF REFERENCE WATER
HAS A SOUL REFLECTANCE ABOUT 10%.
FOREST'S RANGE FROM 5220% CROPS
FROM 18225% GRASS FROM 2230% AND
DESERT FROM 2240% 45%.
OUR INDUSTRY IS A NUMBER OF
CONCERNS WITH AB SIX SIXTY I'M
GONNA FOCUS ON THREE KEY AREAS
CONSUMER COST CONSUMER CHOICE
AND REGULATORY PROCESS --
ASPHALT ROOFING -- REPRESENTS
APPROXIMATELY 80% OF RESIDENTIAL
ROOFING CALIFORNIA OVER FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION SQUARE FEET PER
YEAR OF OF ROOTS ARE INSTALLED --
AND IS LOWEST COST OPTION FOR
LOW RISE RESIDENTIAL BUILDINGS.
TODAY THERE ARE READILY
AVAILABLE ASPHALT ROOFING
PRODUCT OPTIONS THAT ARE
CONSIDERED COOL.
AND MEET OR EXCEED THE CECE'S
CURRENT REFLECTANCE REQUIREMENTS
THERE ARE ZERO ASPHALT ROOFING
MATERIALS AND ZERO WOULD SHAKE
MATERIALS THAT CAN MEET THE
THREAT THRESHOLD SET BY THIS
PROPOSED LEGISLATION.
THE FEW PLAYER CONCRETE TILE AND
METAL ROOFING OPTIONS THAT CAN
COMPLY ARE VIRTUALLY ALL WHITE%
IN COLOR. ZERO ASPHALT SHINGLES
MEANS THAT THE NEXT LOWEST COST
COMPLY AN A LIGHT COLORED
METAL WILL COST THE AVERAGE
HOMEOWNER IN CALIFORNIA ABOUT
THREE TIMES AS MUCH FOR AN
AVERAGE SIZE ROOF GOING FROM
ABOUT SEVENTY FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS FOR THE ROOF. TO TWENTY
ONE THOUSAND TO REPLACE THE ROOF.
IT SHOULD BE NOTED THAT IN MOST
CIRCUMSTANCES A NEW ROOF IS A
NECESSITY AND NOT A LUXURY --
THIS BILL WOULDN'T BE
SIGNIFICANT CONCERN TO THE
WEALTHY BUT COULD BECOME A
POTENTIALLY CRIPPLING TO THOSE
STRUGGLING TO MAKE ENDS MEET AND
SEEKING YOUR AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
BEYOND THE COST HOMEOWNERS WERE
HAVE EXTREMELY LIMITED AESTHETIC
OPTIONS VIRTUALLY ANY COLOR YOU
LIKE SO LONG AS IT'S A SHADE OF
WHITE.
OF THE PRODUCTS CURRENTLY SOLD
IN CALIFORNIA WHITE IS THE LEAST
POPULAR COLOR AND WILL NOT BE
ACCEPTED BY THE MARKET.
EVERY MEMBER OF EVERY
MANUFACTURER REPRESENTED BY OUR
COALITION OFFER SCHOOL ROOFS
UNDER THE CURRENT STANDARD BUT
WHERE IT MAY MAKE SENSE FOR ONE
HOMER BUILDING THAT CERTAINLY
DOESN'T MAKE IT THE RIGHT OPTION
FOR EVERY HOME WE'RE BUILDING.
THERE ARE NUMEROUS MEANS TO SAVE
ENERGY IN A HOME.
FROM A FISHING APPLIANCES TO
EFFICIENT BILL BUILDING
MATERIALS LIKE INSULATION
WINDOWS DOORS AND CITING.
MANY OF THESE ARE FAR MORE COST
EFFECTIVE IN TERMS OF INITIAL
COST AND RETURN ON INVESTMENT
AND WHAT AB TO SIX SIXTY WILL
DICTATE [inaudible]
FINALLY.
THE CDC HAS A STATE GOVERNMENT
APPROVED ROBUST CO DEVELOPMENT
PROCESS WHICH CONSIDERS NEWLY
DEVELOPED AVAILABLE TECHNOLOGIES
AND BY LAW UNDER THE WERE IN ALL
CHRIS STACKED COST JUSTIFICATION.
ARE COMBINED INDUSTRIES OF WORK
DIRECTLY WITH THE COMMISSION
SINCE TWO THOUSAND THREE WHEN
COOL ROOFS FIRST BECAME A TOPIC
OF CONSIDERATION.
WE HAVE RESPONDED TO THE
COMMISSION'S ENERGY EFFICIENCY
TARGETS WITH MATERIALS TO
PROVIDE VALUABLE LEGITIMATE
OPTIONS TO HOMEOWNERS.
THE CDC SHOULD EXAMINE THE
BENEFITS OF ALL EFFICIENT
BUILDING MATERIALS RATHER THAN
BEING BEHOLDEN TO AN UNWIELDY
BILL THAT LIMITS CONSUMER CHOICE
AND IMPOSES SIGNIFICANT COST
BURDENS.
THE COLLECTIVE ROOFING INDUSTRY
ASK THE COMMITTEE TO LET
HOMEOWNERS CONTINUE TO USE
PROVEN MATERIALS AND BE ABLE TO
CHOOSE NOT ONLY THOSE MATERIALS.
BUT ALSO THE MEANS FOR MEETING
ENERGY REQUIREMENTS IN THEIR
HOMES AND TO LET THE CDC
CONTINUE TO DO ITS JOB TO
IMPLEMENT IN ENERGY CODES.
THAT CONSIDER ALL COMPONENTS OF
A HOME OR BUILDING TO MEET
ENERGY EFFICIENCY STANDARDS AND
GOALS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
AND WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST A NO
VOTE THANK YOU.
SIR GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
THOMAS PAPPAS I AM THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF WESTERN STATES
ROOFING CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION
WHOSE CONTRACTOR MEMBERS PROVIDE
INSTALLATION REPAIR SERVICES.
FOR THE RESIDENTIAL COMMERCIAL.
ROOFING CONSUMER ACROSS THE
FIFTEEN WESTERN UNITED STATES
OUR LOW ORGANIZATIONS LARGEST
CONTINGENT CONTRACTOR MEMBERS IS
ARE HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND I'M
HERE T VOICE MY OPPOSITION. TO
THE BILL CURRENTLY BEING
CONSIDERED AB.
SIX SIXTY IN CONCERT WITH MISTER
HITCHCOCK'S REMARKS I OFFER THE
FOLLOWING THREE POINTS FROM THE
CONTRACTORS.
SERVICE PROVIDERS PERSPECTIVE.
FIRST OF ALL. FOR BETTER OR
WORSE CONTRACTORS WILL BE THE
INITIAL CONTEST CONTACT WITH THE
RIPPING CONSUMER ON THESE
PERFORMANCE STANDARDS.
AS SUCH IT IS THEIR
RESPONSIBILITY TO OFFER THEM THE
BEST MOST COUGHED COST EFFECTIVE
WAY. TO EITHER REPAIR OR REPLACE
THE ROOF TO PROVIDE THE CONSUMER
WITH QUOTE UNQUOTE LIMITED
ALTERNATIVES FOR THEIR DECISION
WILL PUT THEM IN A PARTICULARLY
UNTENABLE SITUATION.
CALIFORNIA RIPPING CONSUMERS
HAVE BEEN OFFERED THE BROADEST
ARRAY OF ROOFING PRODUCTS KNOWN
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
WITH A DIVERSE SET OF CLIMACTIC
CONDITIONS AND THAT MAKES OUR
STATE SO WONDERFUL TO LIVE IN.
AND MARKET MARKET ESTABLISH
PRODUCTS PROVIDES MANY
ALTERNATIVES AND ENERGY
EFFICIENT WAYS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY GET QUALITY PRODUCTS AT A
COST.
COST EFFICIENT WAY AND IN THEIR
INSTALLATION THE COCKTAIL MARKET
FORCES THE DRIVE CALIFORNIA TO
BE ONE OF THE TOP STATES IN
TERMS OF DIFFERENT TYPES OF
ROOFING PRODUCTS OFFERED WITHIN
OUR STATE.
IT WOULD BE IN OUR STATE IN OUR
OPINION REDEFINED WHAT IT MEANS
TO BE IN THE MELTING POT THAT IS
CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA'S OF ALL CALIFORNIANS
HAVE ALWAYS BEEN A STATE OF
ALTERNATIVES AND CHOICE IN THIS
LEGISLATION WOULD SEVERELY LIMIT
ITS CITIZENS. TO USE VIABLE AN
EXISTING QUALITY RIPPING.
A BASE PRODUCTS BASED ON
CLIMACTIC AESTHETIC AND ENERGY
EFFICIENT DEEDS. TWO LIMITING
THE TYPE OF ROOF TO BE INSTALLED
BRINGS INTO FOCUS THE NEED FOR
MORE SPECIALIZED LABOR TO
INSTALL THEM THEREBY INCREASING
COSTS TO THE CONSUMER.
WITHIN ALREADY CHALLENGE LABOR
FORCE HERE IN THE WEST MANDATING
ANY TYPE OF STYLE OR ENERGY
EFFICIENT OF THE ROOF OTHER THAN
ALREADY EXISTING CALIFORNIA
HOMEOWNERS WOULD DO NOTHING TO
RELIEVE THIS PROBLEM EFFECTIVE
WOULD EXACERBATED TO A LARGE
EXTENT.
EFFICIENT.
ALREADY.
RT EXISTING QUALITY COST
EFFECTIVE PRODUCTS FOR THE KEY
TO RESPONSIVE MARKET DYNAMIC
LIMITING THAT DYNAMIC IN ANY
FORMALLY TO INCREASING CONSUMER
DISSATISFACTION AND HIGHER
INITIAL COST ESPECIALLY THE
BENEFIT.
IT'S NOT A PARENT IN THE SHORT
TERM.
AND FINALLY CONTRACTORS ARE FOR
EVERYTHING ELSE VERY CODE
SENSITIVE.
AS SUCH.
THEY MUST BE AWARE OF THE ENERGY
BUILDING SEISMIC ANOTHER
REGULATORY FACTORS WHICH THEIR
WHICH GOVERN THEIR INSTALLATION
REPAIR PROCESS AND HAVE FOR A
LONG TIME.
DIFFERENT BUILDING CODES AND
SEVERAL QUOTE UNQUOTE SOURCES OF
TRUTH FOR ENERGY EFFICIENCY
ETCETERA WILL LEAD TO FIELD
CONFUSION DELAYS AND ULTIMATELY
COST TO THE CONSUMERS.
CONTRACTORS IN CALIFORNIA ARE
WELL INFORMED ABOUT BUILDING
CODES ENERGY SEISMIC
REQUIREMENTS THAT GOVERN THE
WORK IN WHICH THAT THEY ARE
DOING.
ADDITIONALLY THE SYSTEMS BY
WHICH CODES ARE MODIFIED OR
UPDATED OUR CELL WE SHOULD LONG
PERIODS OF INTERACTION BETWEEN
THE DESIGNED.
PRODUCT AND INSTALLATION
COMMUTING TO ADD ANOTHER.
ANOTHER SYSTEM INTO THIS ALREADY
WELL ESTABLISHED CODE PROCESS BY
PROVIDING TO PROVIDE THE BEST IN
COST OF COST EFFECTIVE
ALTERNATIVES WILL PROVIDE NO
ADDED BENEFIT TO THE CONSUMER
AND TO THE ROOFING COMMITTEE.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE IT IS FOR THESE THREE
REASONS AND THE CONSISTENT
SUPPORT OF THE FREE ENTERPRISE A
MARKET.
REGULATION SYSTEM THAT WE
RESPECTFULLY URGE NO VOTE ON
THIS ITEM THANK YOU FOR THAT --
DO WE HAVE.
I ASKED -- FOR SUPPORT COMMENTS
BUT NOBODY CAME FORWARD I'M
GONNA ASK ONE MORE TIME BEFORE
WE MOVE ON TO MEMBERS. THIRTY
TRAIN NUMBERS NIKITA CROWDED
WITH THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL HERE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
OKAY A WILL COME TO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS [inaudible]
WE WANT.
I JUST LIKE TO ASK THE
OPPOSITION HERE -- YOU SEEN THE
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS THAT DO
ANYTHING FOR YOU.
CHANGER.
IT IS NOT CHAIR SUBSTANTIVE
ARGUMENT IT DOESN'T.
WHY YEAH I THINK THAT'S A GOOD
QUESTION WELL OUR UNDERSTANDING
OF THE THE OF THE PROPOSED
AMANDA AMENDMENTS OR THAT IT
REVERTS TO AN EARLIER VERSION --
YOU STILL HAVE THE SAME
CHALLENGES NOT ONLY WITH
CIRCUMVENTING THE REGULATORY
PROCESS WITH THE CDC NOT LOOKING
AT DIRECTING THEM SPECIFICALLY
TO LOOK AT ROOFING INSTEAD OF
THE ENTIRE ROOFING SYSTEM WHICH
WOULD INCLUDE INSULATION AND
OTHER MATERIALS THAT OFFER COST.
EFFICIENCY BENEFITS.
OTHER TECHNOLOGIES IN THE HOME
THAT PEOPLE MAY CHOOSE TO INVEST
THEIR MONEY AND TO SAVE ENERGY --
AND IT DOESN'T CHANGE THE AND
TARGET OF 45%.
WHICH WITH.
WHAT WE'RE I WILL RESPECTFULLY
DISAGREE WITH MY MY COLLEAGUE TO
MY LEFT -- THAT -- MATERIALS
WILL BE WHITER SHADE OF WHITE
AND THIS COMES FROM THE TILE
ROOFING INDUSTRY HAS SAID THAT
THEY'RE PART OF OUR COALITION --
THE PILOT PROJECTS WITH THE
MANUFACTURERS OF THE GRANULES I
THINK SOME OF WHOM ARE HERE IN
OPPOSITION TODAY -- IT'S NOT
JUST ASPHALT ROOFING -- IT'S
ASPHALT IT CEDAR SHAKES AND IT
SEVERELY LIMITS THE CHOICE FOR
METAL AND CONCRETE TILE AND AND
AGAIN I MEAN WE'VE WE'VE SEEN
THE PILOT PROJECTS THERE WHITE.
OR HINTS OF COLOR ON WHITE AND
SO LIMITS THAT AND THE COST
AGAIN. FOR THE MATERIAL COST
YOU'RE LOOKING AT AS MUCH AS
TRIPLE THOSE GRANULES ON A
STANDARD SHINGLE.
THE COST IS TAKING THE GRANULES
CRUSHING THEM UP THEY GO THROUGH
A FILTERING PROCESS FOR THESE
COOL TECHNOLOGIES THOSE GRANULES
ARE INDIVIDUALLY COATED WITH
INFRARED PAINTS PIGMENTS.
THAT'S A VERY EXPENSIVE PROCESS
AND WE'RE LOOKING AT PRODUCTS
ACCORDING TO THE MANUFACTURERS
OF THE GRANULES THAT COULD
TRIPLE THE COST OF THAT MATERIAL
ALONE.
NOT TO MENTION THE TOOLING COSTS
THE THE COST FOR COMPLYING WITH
MULTIPLE -- ROOFING MATERIAL
DEMANDS FROM OTHER JURISDICTIONS
AS WELL.
POT I'VE GOT TO SAY THAT -- ARE
YOU KNOW FIRST OF ALL I'D LIKE
TO APPLY THE AUTHOR FOR YOU KNOW
TRYING TO COME UP WITH YELP MORE
WAYS OF YOU'RE TRYING TO REDUCE --
YOUR ENERGY USE.
I I YOU KNOW I I KNOW THAT WE
DID LAST YEAR WE HAVEN'T.
THAT ALL NEW HOME TO GET HAVE
SOLAR WE GET IN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
YOUR PROBLEM IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND I JUST WORRY ABOUT ALL THESE
NEW RULES AND REGULATIONS THAT
ALL IT DOES IS FURTHER
EXACERBATES.
THE COST OF HOUSING IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
A ED -- I THINK THIS IS KIND OF
A WORK AROUND TO THE C. E. C. IS
ALREADY ESTABLISHED PROCESS
WHERE THEY'RE LOOKING AT
EVERYTHING HOLISTICALLY.
AT THE END OF THE DAY WHILE I
BELIEVE THAT WE NEED TO WORK
[inaudible]
YOUR TO FIND MORE WAYS TO REDUCE
CARBON TO TO INCREASE ENERGY
EFFICIENCY -- I'M JUST NOT GONNA
BE ABLE TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
TODAY UNTIL -- YOU KNOW I EITHER
HAVE MORE INFORMATION THAT
CHANGED MY MIND ABOUT STRAP BUT
I I REALLY BELIEVE THE
OPPOSITION.
TO A BETTER JOB OF PRESENTING --
THEIR CASE TO AT LEAST TODAY IN
THIS HEARING.
THANK YOU MISTER AND I I WATCH
ON TV I'M SORRY WAS IN HERE TO
SEE THE PRESENTATION OF PERSON I
HAD ONE QUESTION ABOUT I KNOW
IT'S SOMEONE AND RELATED TO THE
THE FOCUS WHICH IS ON SOLAR
REFLECTANCE BUT IN FROM FROM A
FIRE RESISTANCE PERSPECTIVE JUST
WANTED TO GET.
A LITTLE INSIGHT FROM -- YOU ALL
DO ANY.
ANY PLUSES OR MINUSES OR SORT OF
AN NEUTRAL ON ON THAT MATTER IN
TERMS OF FIRE CODE COMPLY TO
SENSE YEAH I WE DON'T ADDRESS --
FIRE COULD COMPLIANCE I MEAN
THAT'S THERE ARE OTHER AREAS OF
LOT ADDRESS THAT FOR ROOF
MATERIALS ON I'LL REPEAT MYSELF
FOR SENATOR DODD COST
EFFECTIVENESS IS ALREADY IN THE
BILL.
SO IT CANNOT INCREASE COSTS WELL
IN A SIMILAR TO BE CLEAR IT'S
ALSO SHALL CONSIDER RIGHT -- SO
IT'S ALL IT'S NOT A MANDATE IT'S
A THAT'S RIGHT IT'S IT'S NOT A
MANDATE AND IT'S A SHOCK
CONSIDER AND IT THAT THE CHANGE
HAS TO BE THAT.
OF COST EFFECTIVENESS OVER THE
LIFE THE ROOF HAS TO BE
CONSIDERED AS WELL.
IN THE SHOP.
RIGHT SOME.
SHALL MEET ALL YOUR LOOK LIKE
AND EIGHT BUT IT'S REALLY THE
CONSIDERATIONS RIGHT SO THE BUT
I SEE YEARS THAT THERE'S
DISCRETION TO SAY NO FRUSTRATED
CC YEP SO AND WE'VE ALREADY
HEARD TESTIMONY THE COLORS AS
DIVERSE AS RED AND BLACK --
COULD MEET THE STANDARD.
OKAY THANKS CAN I SPEAK TO THE
TO THE FIRE NO NO SIR.
I'M SORRY JUST FOLLOW THIS.
DID ANYBODY ELSE WANT TO SPEAK
YEAH.
WE HAD ALL THIS. TO THE RIGHT
KNOW I THINK THE THE IDEA IS
GREAT AND AS WE TALKED EARLIER
TODAY I DON'T KNOW WITH THE
AMENDMENTS SOMEHOW I WILL
SUPPORT THE BILL I DO HAVE
CONCERNS ESPECIALLY IN.
THE AREA THAT I COME FROM IN THE
CLIMATE THAT WE LIVE IN -- DOES
YOU KNOW I THINK THIS WOULD BE
CHALLENGING AND CERTAINLY COLORS
OF A CONSIDERATION FOR ROOF XIN.
AND I THINK THAT THE SCIENCE MAY
NOT BE THERE TO TO DO THAT BUT
YOU KNOW I'LL BE HAPPY TO MOVE
THE BILL BUT IS CERTAINLY WILL.
LOOK AT IT IT APPROPRIATIONS AND
AND AS IT COMES TO THE FLOOR TO
SEE IF.
IT GIVES MORE THOUGHT TO THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
I'M JUST CURIOUS -- SINCE CC ARI
ODDS THE THIRTY TO DO THIS AND
HASN'T.
AND THEY FEEL IT'S NOT COST
EFFECTIVE.
WHAT TO WHAT CHANGES HERE?
YEAH SURE -- THANKS SO THE AT
LUNCH ONE LOOK AT IT.
SO THE ANSWER IS THAT THE CDC
HAD BEEN OPERATING ON THE
ASSUMPTIONS OF WORK THAT WE
ACTUALLY DID LBNL AND THE BASE
THE CODE ON WHAT THE BENEFITS
WOULD BE FOR NEW HOMES.
WE DID RECENT ANALYSIS FOR
ANOTHER PROJECT FUNDED BY THE
ENERGY COMMISSION AND THAT'S WE
REALIZE THAT THE POTENTIAL FOR
ENERGY SAVINGS WERE ABOUT TEN
TIMES GREATER THAN HAD BEEN
ASSUMED BEFORE.
AND THAT CHANGES THE EQUATION.
SO THAT'S THE NEWS [inaudible]
OKAY.
BUT THAT STILL DOESN'T SPEAK TO
WHY THE CC HASN'T DONE THEIR JOB
AND LOOKING AT THIS PART TO THE
YOU MAY CONSIDER THIS NEW
INFORMATION THAT'S BEEN
DEVELOPED OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS AND IS NOW BEEN BROUGHT TO
BE SO THEY WILL BE ENTERTAINING
MENTION.
THE LABORATORY TO DO THE
RESEARCH FOR THEM IN ORDER THE
MOVE.
FOR YOU COULD SAY THAT I CAN'T
SPEAK FOR THEM -- BUT I WILL SAY
THAT THE ENERGY COMMISSION DOES
OFTEN RELY ON RESEARCH AND IN
THIS CASE WAS RESEARCH THAT IT
HAD FUNDED FOR ANOTHER PROJECT.
IN THIS BROUGHT TO LIGHT THE
OPPORTUNITY -- SENATOR RUBIO
CLOVER CENTER DR.
THANK YOU -- I REALLY HAVE GIVEN
IT MUCH THOUGHT TO THIS BILL IN
PARTICULAR BECAUSE I KNOW WHAT
OUR GOALS ARE AS CALIFORNIANS.
BUT I HAVE A LOT OF CONFLICTS AS
IT PERTAINS TO YOU KOW
PORTANTINO IN DIFFERENT AREAS OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND I'VE BEEN HEARING SOME OF
THE AYE SUPPORTERS AND OPPONENTS
AND I THINK ULTIMATELY FOR ME
THE BIGGEST CONCERN RIGHT NOW IS
THAT.
OUR HOUSING CRISIS WHICH IS
REALLY A BIG ISSUE AND DIE
GETTING PEOPLE.
TO NOT ONLY GET HIM OFF THE
STREETS ARE HOMELESSNESS PROBLEM
BUT YOU KNOW THE AFFORDABILITY
ISSUE AND I THINK THAT WE CAN
TEACH TO ADD.
A MORE REGULATIONS.
MORE REQUIREMENTS AND I FEEL
LIKE AT THIS POINT I'M NOT SURE
I SEE.
AND PERHAPS THAT'S MY DEFICIENCY
AND I SHOULD HAVE YOU KNOW.
I'VE BEEN RESEARCHING BUT I
DON'T SEE IT RIGHT NOW I DON'T
SEE HOW THIS IS GONNA SOLVE THAT
PROBLEM IN TERMS OF YOU KNOW I
DID HEAR I DID SPEAK TO SOME OF
THE THE INDUSTRY FOLKS AND THEIR
SHARE WITH ME -- JUST BE AN
ABILITY TO HAVE CHOICE FOR FOR
CONSUMERS BEING ABLE.
TO DESIGN THEIR HOME IN A
PARTICULAR WAY IN OUR
PRESCRIBING HOW THEY DO THEIR
HOME AND AND SO I'M HAVING A LOT
OF CONFLICTS LIKE I REALLY WANT
TO SUPPORT IT BUT IN THIS MOMENT
I JUST FEEL WE'RE ADDING ONE
MORE LAYER. TWO PEOPLE THAT
CAN'T AFFORD HOMES ONE MORE
LAYER.
TO OUR HOUSING CRISIS ONE MORE
LAYER. TO TO A PROBLEM WE'RE
TRYING TO SOLVE AND SO AT THIS
POINT I I FEEL LIKE ANYWHERE
MORE INFORMATION -- PERHAPS
LATER I CAN JUMP ON BOARD IF I
CAN.
GET MORE RESEARCH MORE
INFORMATION MORE CONCRETE DATA
AS TO HOW THIS HELPS BUT T THIS
POINT I'M HAVING TROUBLE
SUPPORTING AND I WANTED
EXPRESSED.
YEAH THANK YOU SENATOR -- I
THINK A LOT OF YOUR CONCERNS CAN
BE ADDRESSED ALREADY WE ARE
RESTRICTED BY THE MATERIALS WE
CAN USE FOR HOMES FOR EXAMPLE I
LIVE IN A WILD IN URBAN
INTERFACE I CANNOT PUT WHATEVER
CITING I WANT ON MY HOME BECAUSE
OF WHERE I LIVE -- WE DO THIS
AND SO MANY OTHER PLACES IN HOME
CONSTRUCTION MATERIALS --
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA -- IN SO BUT I THINK
PRIMARILY THE THE CONCERN I'VE
HEARD NOT JUST FROM YOU BUT FROM
OTHERS IS THE COST.
ONE HOW TO SOLVE OUR HOUSING
PROBLEM AND SO THE COST LONG
TERM.
PROBABLY BE IT WILL BE LOWER
BECAUSE OF THE THE HEATING AND
COOLING SAVINGS FOR HOMEOWNERS.
AND PEOPLE NEED TO REPLACE THE
RIFFS ANYWAY.
SO THIS IS CATCHING PEOPLE WHEN
THEY REPLACE THE ROOF THAT WILL
GIVE THEM A LONGER TERM SAVINGS.
AND AGAIN.
IN THE BILL ITSELF COST
EFFECTIVENESS MUST BE CONCERT
THAT CONSIDERED.
SO WE WILL NOT BE IN THE BILL
DOESN'T MANDATE ANYTHING FIRST
OF ALL.
AND SECONDLY NOTHING WILL BE
MANDATED THAT IS MORE EXPENSIVE --
THROUGH THE BILL AS WELL.
AND I DOCTOR LEVINSON HAS SOME
COMMENTS ON THIS POINT AS WELL
SURE IT'S OKAY WILL WILL WILL.
BUDGET ARE YOU ARE YOU.
THEY SATISFY YOUR QUESTION WILL.
WILL MOVE ON AND IF I COULD JUST --
YOU KNOW.
I I REPRESENT AREA WHERE OF
TEMPERATURES YOU GET TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE DEGREES AND OFTEN
TIMES IF -- IF THERE WERE
CERTAIN CONSTRUCTION STANDARDS
IN THOSE AREAS IN THIS BILL.
TARGET CERTAIN AREAS THAT HAVE
HIGH -- WORRY IT EXTREME
CLIMATES -- SOMETIMES IT COULD
BE A MATTER OF LIFE AND DEATH
FOR SOME PEOPLE OUT THERE --
THAT HAVE PROBLEMS WITH ENERGY
YOU OR HAVE A AIR CONDITIONER
THAT GOES OUT.
ANYTHING THAT WE CAN DO TO
MINIMIZE HEATING OF THE HOUSES
IT COULD BE VERY IMPORTANT IN
THOSE AREAS I THINK THIS BILL
GETS.
TO COMING UP WITH STANDARDS THAT
ADDRESS -- GEOGRAPHICAL --
EXTREMES IN OUR STATE AND SO
WHAT WE LOOK AT THIS BILL --
NOTHING STOPS THE COMMISSION
FROM ALSO CONSIDERING.
OTHER PRODUCTS THAT MAY HELP.
REDUCE -- THE THE HEAT OF THE
HOME.
AND WE ALSO PUT IN -- IN INTO
THE AMENDMENT.
AWESOME CONTROLS AND DEAL WITH --
THE AVAILABILITY OF LABOR THAT
WAS AN ARGUMENT BROUGHT UP THE
THE THE THE OF THE BILL
ADDRESSES THE THE ISSUE OF LABOR
RESOURCES AND ALSO.
WHETHER PRODUCTS EXIST THAT MEET
THE STANDARD ALSO ADDRESSES THAT
AND ALSO GETS TO COST SO.
WE HAVE TO MOVE IN A DIRECTION
TO HELP.
REDUCE ENERGY CONSUMPTION
ANYTHING WE CAN DO BE VERY
HELPFUL.
AND FOR THE AREAS THAT I
REPRESENT I THINK THE PEOPLE BE
BETTER SERVE HAVING PRODUCTS
THAT ALREADY HAVE A REFLECTIVE.
A GRADIENT AND AT THAT -- WILL
HELP THEM.
A SAVE ENERGY MANY TIMES
CONSUMERS AREN'T AWARE OF THAT.
IF WE CAN HELP GUIDE THEM AND
MAKING SURE THEY HAVE A PRODUCT
THAT ENSURES LOWER COSTS IN
THEIR ENERGY BILL.
THAT WOULD HELP FOR TWENTY YEARS
SO YOU KNOW I JUST PUT MY ROOF
MY QUESTION IS IS MY ROOF.
ADEQUATE MY HOME HEATS -- BUT
WHATEVER I SAVED IN.
IN MY ROOF I'M PROBABLY PAIN IN
MY ENERGY COSTS.
AND I'M GONNA BE PAYING THAT FOR
TWENTY YEARS THE LIFE OF THE
ROOF UNLESS I REPLACE AND HAVE
TO GO THROUGH THAT OTHER PROCESS
WHICH AGAIN IS GOING TO BE AN
ADDITIONAL EXPENSE WHICH I THINK
WOULD NOT BE FRIENDLY ON
CONSUMERS EITHER.
ONCE THEY REALIZE THEY HAVE A
LARGE ELECTRIC BILL.
SO IF WE COULD ENTERTAIN A
MOTION ON THIS BILL IF IT'S A
PLEASURE OF THE COMMITTEE WE
HAVE A MOTION -- CLERK PLEASE
CALL.
I'M SORRY WE HAD A WITNESS --
SQUIRM WE ALREADY HAD.
A QUICKLY CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
HUESO.
HERE WAS SO HERE MARLA.
MORE LIKE PRESENT BRADFORD.
BEDFORD HERE CHIANG DODD YOUR
DIED HERE HERTZBERG HILL.
KILL HERE MCGUIRE RUBIO.
RUBIO HERE SKINNER STERN.
STERN HERE STONE DOWN HERE
WINNER.
NOW CAN WIENER TENEMOS ENTERTAIN
A MOTION ON THE BILL.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
STERN.
LOOK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB SIX SIXTY TWO PASSES AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS WEST SO I WAS
SO I MOORLACH.
MORE LIKE NO BRADFORD.
CHIANG DIED.
DODD NO HERTZBERG HILL.
HILL AYE MCGUIRE RUBIO.
SKINNER STERN STERN AYE STONE
STONE NO WIENER. THREE OKAY THE
VOTE HAS THREE VOTES WILL KEEP
THE ROLL OPEN OR ABSENT MEMBERS
CAN WE ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON
ITEM NUMBER ONE IS GOING TO SAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU CENTERS OKAY.
ALL.
OF THE MOST.
YEAH OUT WE HAVE A MOTION ON A.
B. TWO FIVE FIVE TWO THREE BUYS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN.
CLICK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE PASS IS AMENDED TO THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE WEST SO I
HUESO I MORE NOT [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I CHANGE DODD
[inaudible]
HERTZBERG START.
HI.
DODD I HILL.
HILL AYE MCGUIRE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SKINNER STERN.
STERN AYE STONE [inaudible]
WIENER.
NEEDS FOR MARKET.
OKAY -- WILL KEEP THE ROLE FOR
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS WILL MOVE ON
TO ITEM NUMBER THREE AB.
NINE ELEVEN I LIKE THAT. NINE
ELEVEN FOR A JOB SELECT AND BILL
NUMBER -- WE HAVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RODRIGUEZ HERE WELCOME.
ONE OF THE S..
THANK A ROMAN CENTER IN MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL.
NINE ELEVEN THIS MEASURES THE
FIRST STEP TOWARD ESTABLISHING A
SMART NINE ONE ONE STATEWIDE
SYSTEM WHICH WILL ENABLE PERSONS
TO VOLUNTARY CEMENT HEALTH.
BAR HEALTH INFORMATION TO
AVAILABLE FOR ALL FOR SPONSORS.
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO EIGHT
MILLION PERSONS WERE ORDERED
ALSO PERSONS WITH MOBILITY
CENTURY INTELLECTUAL DEVELOPMENT
TO AND OR MENTAL HEALTH
DISABILITIES.
THESE INDIVIDUALS ARE CONSIDERED
AT RISK HAVE UNIQUE NEEDS AND
REGULARLY REQUIRE SPECIAL
ACCOMMODATIONS ESPECIALLY DURING
THE CASES OF MUNCIE WORK.
THEY MAY NOT BE A CLEARLY
COMMUNICATE WITH FOR
TRANSPONDERS.
IN ORDER TO BETTER SERVE AT RISK
INDIVIDUALS AND MINIMISE ANY
RISK OF INJURY.
IT IS CRITICAL THAT OFFER FOR
SPONSORS FIRE LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND EMS.
BE PROVIDED WITH A PERSON VITAL
HEALTH INFORMATION PRIOR TO
ARRIVING ON SCENE.
HOW TO FROM WHICH WOULD INCLUDE
KNOWN MEDICAL CONDITIONS
MEDICATIONS AND EMERGENCY
CONTACTS?
EACH BEING A CRITICAL PIECE OF
INFORMATION FOR FIRST RESPONDERS.
MEMBERS THIS WILL BE A SYSTEM
THAT WILL KEEP OUR MOST
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIA'S SAFER
AND BETTER PREPARE OUR FIRST
RESPONDERS.
WITH ME TO TODAY TO TESTIFY
SUPPORTERS ESTROGEN AGO VICE
PRESIDENT OF UT W..
AND THERESA FROM THE A. R. C. OF
CALIFORNIA.
SIR TERRY MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THREE THING ANDERSON ON
BEHALF OF THE ARC IN UNITED
CEREBRAL PALSY CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATION WE'RE COSPONSORS
OF THE BILL.
AND URGE YOUR SUPPORT I'M IN
INTERESTED TIME I'M GONNA DEFER
MY TIME TO MR ANY ZONING AS THIS
IS HER LIVED EXPERIENCE AND SHE
CAN EXPLAIN IT THE NEED FOR THIS
BILL.
BETTER THAN ANYBODY.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS --
YES MY NAME IS ASTRAZENECA AND
THE EXECUTIVE VICE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED DOMESTIC WORKERS
ASKED ME LOCAL.
THIRTY NINE THIRTY WE REPRESENT
A LITTLE OVER A HUNDRED AND TEN
THOUSAND HOME CARE PROVIDERS
ACROSS THE STATE -- WHOSE
CLIENTS WOULD BENEFIT FROM A
PROGRAM SUCH AS THIS.
BUT FIRST AND FOREMOST I AM A
MOTHER I AM THE MOTHER OF ANY
WHO THE ACT WILL BE NAMED AFTER.
HE IS A AN ADULT ARTISTIC WHO IS
TWENTY YEARS OLD HE IS NONVERBAL
HE'S ALSO COMBATIVE HE'S
EPILEPTIC HE'S A RUNNER HAS NO
FEAR OF WATER HEIGHTS CARS.
THINGS OF THAT SORT.
SO I HAVE MADE IT MY MISSION TO
ENSURE THAT WE ARE PROVIDING ALL
FIRST RESPONDERS WITH ADEQUATE
TRAINING.
TOOLS TO BETTER ASSIST THEM AND
HAVING BETTER SAFER INTERACTIONS
WITH INDIVIDUALS LIKE SUCH AS MY
SON.
I'M I HAVE TRAVELED UP AND DOWN
THE STATE I HAVE MET WITH
SEVERAL MINUTES POLITIES FROM
SAN DIEGO AND THE TAKE ME HOME
PROGRAM TO SANTA CLARITA AND
THEIR SPECIAL NEEDS PROGRAM.
GROVE IN KERN COUNTY WHO APPS --
AND ONE TYPE PROGRAM.
AND THEY ARE ALL INDIVIDUALLY
DOING SOMETHING BUT WE NEED ONE
STATEWIDE COHESIVE PROGRAM.
SO THAT IF I PROVIDE MY SON'S
INFORMATION IN ADVANCE
PROACTIVELY BUT I TAKE HIM TO
DISNEYLAND AND HE GOES MISSING
THEY WOULD HAVE ACCESS TO THAT
INFORMATION -- AND IN DOING THIS
WE ARE NOT ONLY CREATING A SAFER
ENVIRONMENT FOR OUR COMMUNITIES
MOST VULNERABLE BUT WE'RE ALSO
ENSURING THAT OUR FIRST
RESPONDERS.
ARE ADEQUATELY TRAINED.
PROVIDED TOOLS.
I'M AND FOR THIS REASON I MANY
OTHERS BECAUSE I COULD SIT HERE
ALL DAY AND CONTINUE TO GO ON
SOME OF YOU HAVE ALREADY HEARD
ME AND THE LAST COMMITTEE OR
I'VE BEEN IN OFFICES.
I AM I JUST URGE YOU OFFICE.
I VOTE ON THIS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU.
UGH ANY OTHERS SPEAKERS IN FAVOR.
GEN STEVEN WEBER CALIFORNIA
ASKED ME IS STRONG SUPPORT.
ANYONE ELSE DO WE HAVE SPEAKERS
IN OPPOSITION.
MANY ONE OKAY -- JUST WANT TO
MAKE SOME COMMENTS REGARDING --
SOME INFORMATION.
THAT WE ARE STILL LOOKING INTO
AN AND THE RAISES ENORMOUS
CONCERNS THIS BILL.
IS A GREAT BILL I LOVE WHAT IT
DOES AND I LOVE WHAT IT DOES
WITH FOR PEOPLE THAT ARE AT RISK
THAT CAN GO [inaudible]
OF OFTENTIMES -- UP.
BECOME SEPARATED FROM THEIR
THEIR THEIR SERVICE PROVIDERS OR
OTHER SUPPORT SERVICES OR THE
PEOPLE THAT CAN.
HELP LOOK AFTER THEM -- THE
CONCERN THAT I HAVE RAISED BY
ACLU REGARDING THE RACIAL THE
POSSIBILITY OF USING THE STATE
OF FOR RACIAL PROFILING.
AND THAT'S BECOMING A A GREATER
CONCERN THESE DAYS WITH
EVERYTHING THAT'S HAPPENED.
NATION WIDE AND AND AND AND IN
REGARDS TO IDENTITY THEFT AND IN
REGARDS TO GATHERING DATA -- FOR
THE USE YOU KNOW. FOR FOR THE
USE OF A THE PEOPLE THAT HAVE --
PROBLEMS DEALING WITH.
IN ORDER FOR CITY IN OUR
COMMUNITY [inaudible]
BUT YOU KNOW WE HAVEN'T HAD
ENOUGH TIME TO REALLY GET INTO
THAT ISSUE WITH ACLU AND NO I
JUST WANT TO ASK IF THAT
SOMETHING THAT YOU'RE AWARE OF
THESE VALUES CONCERNS AND IF YOU
TALK TO THEM ABOUT THAT IF
YOU'VE SEEN THE POSSIBILITY OF
FIX THAT THROUGH THIS.
BILL YES CENTER ACTUALLY THAT
WASN'T REGION IN THE LANGUAGE
BUT WHEN AS AN ASSEMBLY CNC
COMMITTEE THEY ASKED ME TO PUT
THAT LANGUAGE AND TO GET IT OUT
OF COMMITTEE CI AND I'M AWARE OF
THEM WHEN I'M LOOKING OUT THE
PHARMACY GETS OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE TO ADDRESS IT.
IN THE JUDICIARY COULD BE THE
NEXT WE'RE GOING TO SEE ABOUT
REMOVING THAT LANGUAGE OR MAKING
A BETTER FOR EACH YEAR AND LET'S
SEE IF YOU WE WE CAN WORK WITH
THE COMMITTEE THAT AT THAT
LANGUAGE.
MAYBE THEY DON'T KNOW THE
CHALLENGES THAT OPPOSES WE WANT
WE WANT TO KEEP THIS NUMBER ONE
FOUR THANK YOU.
FOR YOUR QUESTION THANK YOU
THANK YOU -- CENTER RUBIO.
YES THANK YOU -- WEALTH KERR IS
AND I ALSO SHARE THE SAME
CONCERNS ABOUT ACLU BT WHEN IT
COMES TO AN ISSUE ESPECIALLY FOR
MOTHER DEALING WITH A CHILD WITH
SUCH YOU KNOW SIT HERE --
DISABILITIES I THINK SOMETIMES
UP SAVING A LIFE IS WORTH.
THAT RISK IN TERMS OF YOU KNOW
AND I HOPE THAT YOU TO WORK WITH
A SO YOU TO MINIMIZE THOSE
CONCERNS BUT HAVING BEEN A VICE
PRINCIPAL TO SCHOOL WHERE WE
DEALT WITH ALSO AUTISTIC KIDS IN
AND IT'S A CHALLENGE TO TO KEEP
THEIR SAFETY.
AND MINE BUT I KNOW THAT IT ALSO
TRICKLES DOWN TO THE SAFETY OF
OTHERS SO.
IF I UNDERSTAND CORRECTLY IF A
POLICE OFFICER SHOWS UP TO YOUR
HOME OR ANYWHERE THEY WOULD KNOW
THAT THIS CHILD HAS SPECIAL
NEEDS.
AND WE'VE SEEN A LOT OF OF
PEOPLE GET SHOT BECAUSE YOU KNOW
THE PUBLIC CITY DOESN'T
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE'S A
DISABILITY THEIR SOUL THE THEIR
AGGRESSIVE IN.
THE FIRST AN INSTINCT IS TO
SHOOT SO I THINK THAT THIS WOULD
BE A GREAT STEP TOWARDS SAVING
SOME LIVES IN EDUCATING PEOPLE
AND AND ANOTHER STILL SOME
CHALLENGES AND I'M CONFIDENT
THAT YOU'LL CONTINUE TO WORK ON
IT AND MAKE SURE THAT WE
MINIMIZE THAT -- ABILITY TO
RACIAL LEE PROFILE PEOPLE THAT
IS A CONCERN OF MINE BUT I THINK
THE SAFETY OF OF OUR COMMUNITY
ALSO IS.
A BIGGER CONCERN SO I WILL BE
SUPPORTING IT THANK YOU.
WINNER CHEN MOTION ON THE BILL.
HEY DID YOU WANNA MAKE A CLOSING
COMMENTS.
JUST RESPECT PLEASURABLE THANK
YOU CLICK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
DO YOU PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON JUDICIARY [inaudible]
WEST SO.
I WAS SO I MOORLACH BRADFORD
CHIANG DODD.
DODD AYE HERTZBERG HILL HILL AYE
MCGUIRE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SKINNER STERN.
STERN ICE DOWN STONE AYE WIENER
[inaudible]
IT'S ONE LOOK IT WILL KEEP THE
ROVER PREPS MEMBERS.
THANK YOU WILL MOVE ON TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING ON ITEM NUMBER FOUR
A. B. [inaudible]
TEN TWENTY EIGHT GOOD MORNING
[inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
SO THIS IS THE EASIEST GONZALEZ
BILL YOU'LL EVER HAVE VOTE ON
RIGHT.
MISTER DODD AGREES -- THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS ASSEMBLY
BILL TEN TWENTY EIGHT WOULD
SUPPORT LOCAL SCHOOL AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT
EFFORTS TO INSTALL COST
EFFECTIVE ENERGY PROJECTS BY
EXPANDING THE LIST OF ELIGIBLE
EXPENDITURES UNDER THE CLEAN
ENERGY JOB CREATION FRONT.
IN TWENTY TWELVE CALIFORNIA
VOTERS APPROVED PROPOSITION
THIRTY NINE A MEASURE THAT
INCREASED STATE REVENUES BY ONE
BILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
IN ALLOCATED HALF OF THE REVENUE
TO THE CLEAN ENERGY JOB CREATION
FUND FOR ENERGY PROJECTS
STATEWIDE.
AS OF JUNE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
APPROXIMATELY ONE POINT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS IN PROP THIRTY
NINE PROJECTS WERE APPROVED.
AT K. THROUGH TWELVE SCHOOLS.
GOING TO SEE SEE THESE PROJECTS
WILL PRODUCE AN ESTIMATED A
HUNDRED AND FIVE MILLION IN
ANNUAL ENERGY COST SAVINGS AND
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS.
THIS BILL WILL EXPAND THE LIST
OF EXPENDITURES TO INCLUDE
EMPLOYEE TRAINING AND ENERGY
MANAGERS THAT WILL HELP MAINTAIN
AND MONITOR THESE PROJECTS.
ADDITIONALLY AND PROVIDING
GRANTS ALLOCATIONS A CC WILL
PRIORITIZE PROJECTS THAT UTILIZE
STATE APPROVED APPRENTICESHIP
AND PRE PARTNERSHIP PROGRAMS.
BY EXPANDING THE CLEAN ENERGY
JOB CREATION PROGRAM CALIFORNIA
CAN TAKE STEPS TOWARD MEETING
OUR CLIMATE GOALS WHILE REDUCING
ENERGY COSTS FOR SCHOOLS AND
PROVIDING PIPELINE FOR SKILLED
WORKFORCE.
I HAVE THE ORDERS WITH ME OKAY.
DAVE WALRATH REPRESENTING THE
SCHOOL ENERGY COALITION.
IN ADDITION TO THE BENEFITS
ALREADY OUTLINED BY THE AUTHOR.
THERE HAVE BEEN ALREADY ALMOST
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND JOBS CREATED
COULD PAIN MIDDLE CLASS JOBS TO
THIS PROGRAM.
THE SAVINGS SO THAT ARE COULD BY
SCHOOL DISTRICTS WILL BACK INTO
THE CLASSROOM FOR HIGH PRIORITY
EDUCATIONAL EXPENDITURES AND
INVESTMENTS.
AND LASTLY.
WE HAVE A ONE POINT THREE SIX A
SAVINGS TO EXPENDITURE RATIO
WHICH IS VERY VERY HIGH RATIO
AND SHOWS THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
THIS PROGRAM.
WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH DO YOU
HAVE ANY OTHER SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT.
WHEN MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MIKE
MONNA GOING TO BE HALF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
ELECTRICAL WORKERS THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PARK TRADES
COUNCIL?
IN THE WESTERN STATES COUNCIL
SHEET METAL WORKERS IN SUPPORT.
OKAY AND POWER TRAIN ON BEHALF
NEXT IN CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING I'M CATHERINE
GARCIA ON BEHALF OF SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA ALSO THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF CONSERVATION VOTERS
AND THE ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE
FUND IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE TO HAVE
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
NONE.
AT CENTER HELP THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR YOU KNOW THIS BILL PASSED
OUT OF THE SENATE LABOR
COMMITTEE LAST WEEK -- WITH IT
WAS A GREAT BILL THEN AND IT'S
EVEN THE EVEN GREATER BILL THIS
WEEK FROM HAVING TO MOVE IT AT
THE PROPER TIME.
OKAY OKAY AND THE BILL ARRIVED
IN GOOD ORDER IT WAS AN AMENDED
SO.
THE ONE QUICK QUESTION.
YES THE SPECIALIST HERE THANK
YOU SENT OVER -- JUST.
WE DIDN'T TALK WITH THE STATE OF
THE PROP THIRTY NINE FUNDS WHAT
WHAT'S LEFT IT.
WELL.
YOU KNOW THE UNSPOKEN TRUTH AS
WE HAVE NO MONEY TO FUND THE
SPELL AND SO -- PART OF
CONTINUING TO PUSH THAT -- IS
CONTINUING TO HAVE THAT
DISCUSSION TO BRING IT FORWARD
HOPEFULLY TO THE GOVERNOR TO SEE
SOME PRIORITIES AND HOW WE
ACTUALLY -- CREATE A PROGRAM
THAT THAT EXTENDS BEYOND THE
FUNDS WHICH NO LONGER EXIST
OBVIOUSLY.
THAT'S A VERY WORTHY ENDEAVOR
BECAUSE I MEAN WE HAD IT WITH A
LOT OF SUCCESS AND HE WAS A
SMART TO LANE CAN SORT OF THINK
GOING FORWARD BUT YEAH HOW DO WE
FILL THE GAP HERE MEANS SO
RARELY DO WE HAVE A PROGRAM THAT.
ACTUALLY REDUCES GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS -- PROVIDES GOOD
QUALITY AT TRAINING AND JOBS --
MC'S OUR SCHOOL MONEY I MEAN
THERE'S LIKE.
THE TRI FACTOR OF A PROGRAM YET
WE NEED TO GET THE ATTENTION --
I THINK OF THAT OUR OUR BUDGET
COMMITTEES THIS GOVERNOR -- SOME
FOLKS WHO CAN ACTUALLY FUND THIS
PROGRAM VERY GOOD ALTHOUGH THE
BILL WHENEVER APPROPRIATE WE
HAVE A HE ALREADY MOVED IT --
CLICK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL DID
YOU WANNA MAKE ANY CLOSING
COMMENTS.
THE CLASS AND I WENT TO A CLUB
PLEASE CALL.
DO YOU PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
WEST SO I WAS SO I MORE LACK
BRADFORD CHIANG DODD AYE DODD
AYE HERTZBERG HILL.
HILL AYE MCGUIRE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SKINNER STERN STERN
ICE DOWN STONE AYE WIENER.
SHE WAS LAST.
ONE WAS THESE.
LOOK AT THE REAL OPEN CRESCENT
MEMBERS.
NOW WE'LL MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER
SIX AB ELEVEN FORTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN WELCOME
GOOD MORNING.
HOW ARE YOU?
WELL GOOD.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR THOUGHTFUL
ANALYSIS SOME FOR WORKING WITH
ME ON THE BILL.
A TRUE AS WE KNOW TRANSPORTATION
CONTINUES TO BE ONE OF THE MAIN
SOURCES WHERE WE HAVE BEEN GOING
INTHE WRONG DIRECTION.
IN TERMS OF EMISSION REDUCTIONS
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR NOW
ACCOUNTS FOR ABOUT 40% OF THE
STATE'S TOTAL MISSIONS AND THAT
NUMBER IS UNFORTUNATELY GROWING.
AND WE'RE NOT IN THE TRAJECTORY
OF MEETING OUR TRANSPORTATION
GHG EMISSIONS FOR TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY IN -- TWO THOUSAND THIRTY
FIVE ONE OF THE CHALLENGES THAT
CARB HAD -- IDENTIFIED IN THERE
ONE FIFTY REPRESSED BE ONE FIFTY
REPORT IS THAT TN SEES -- DON'T
GIVE ENOUGH INFORMATION TO
TRANSIT AGENCIES FOR THEM TO
ACCURATELY USE THEIR SERVICES
WITH REGARD TO THEIR PLANNING
AND IF THEY DON'T KNOW WHERE
PEOPLE PEOPLE ARE TAKING TEA AND
SEASON WAY AND IT'S VERY HARD
FOR THEM TO FILL IN GAPS OF
SERVICE.
SO WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS IT
WORKS TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR NPOS
INCLUDE METRICS ABOUT TNC SAYS
PART OF THE REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION PLANS.
THE BILL ALSO REQUIRES A
TRANSPORTATION PLANS TO INCLUDE
MEASUREMENTS REGARDING BARRIERS
UTILIZATION OF PUBLIC TRANSIT
INCLUDING TRANSFERRED FREQUENCY
PARKING AND FACILITIES FOR
BICYCLES AND I GUESS FOR
SCOOTERS.
TO I'M IN ADDITION AB ELEVEN
FORTY TWO DIRECTS THE CPU SEEM
TO CONSIDER THE NEES OF NPOS
AND OTHER STATE AND LOCAL
AGENCIES. TO MEET THEIR
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITY STRATEGY
GOALS WHEN DECIDE WHEN DECIDING
ON TNC DATA REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS. TO BE CLEAR NPOS
IN OTHER TRANSPORTATION AND
THESE NEED APPROPRIATE DATA IN
ORDER TO IMPLEMENT THE POLICIES
TO REDUCE THE USE OF SINGLE
OCCUPANCY VEHICLES INCREASE
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION OPPOSITION.
AND TO REDUCE GREENHOUSE GASES
AS WE HAVE REQUIRED THEM TO DO.
THIS UPDATE TO THE REQUIREMENTS
OF THE REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION
PLANS AND ADDED DIRECTION TO THE
C. P. UC'S RECORDING REGARDING
TNC DATA REPORTING WILL IMPROVE
THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
TRANSPORTATION POLICIES.
I WILL HELP CALIFORNIA MEET ITS
LONG TERM CLIMATE TRANSPORTATION
GOALS.
NOW THE OPPOSITION HAS GIVEN US
A MEMONS RECENTLY AND WE HAVE
YET TO FULLY BE ABLE TO REVIEW
THOSE AMENDMENTS BUT WE ARE
COMMITTED TO DOING THAT AND TO
WORKING WITH THEM AS THE BILL
MOVES FORWARD.
I BELIEVE THAT WE CAN ADDRESS
THE IMPORTANT ISSUES HIGHLIGHTED
IN THE SP ONE FIFTY REPORT WHILE
SIMULTANEOUSLY PROTECTING USER
PRIVACY AND NOT IMPOSING OVERLY.
ONEROUS REQUIREMENTS ON THE TNC
IS WE'VE HAD VERY PRODUCTIVE
MEETINGS WITH THEM JUST THIS
WEEK TO TALK ABOUT WAYS THAT WE
CAN TAILOR THIS TO MAKE SURE
IT'S WORKABLE FOR THEM BUT ALSO
TO GIVE OUR OUR AGENCIES THE
DATA THAT THEY NEED -- WITH ME
TODAY TO TESTIFY IS CATHERINE
GARCIA ON BEHALF OF YOUR CALL
CALIFORNIA AND I THINK DAVE
SNYDER MIGHT BE HERE FROM
CALIFORNIA BICYCLE HI DAVE FROM
CALIFORNIA BICYCLE COALITION.
A THANKS SO MUCH IN ADVANCE AND
I APPRECIATE ALL OF YOUR
CONSIDERATION.
GOOD MORNING TERRY MEMBERS MY
NAME IS KATHERINE GARCIA ON
BEHALF OF SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA.
WHICH INCLUDES FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND MEMBERS AND SUPPORTERS
STATEWIDE WE STRONGLY SUPPORT AB.
ELEVEN FORTY TWO THIS BILL WITH
THAT REQUIREMENTS TO HELP LOCAL
PENNY AGENCIES MEET CALIFORNIA'S
LONG TERM TRANSPORTATION AND
CLIMATE GOALS.
CALIFORNIA IS NOT ON TRACK TO
MEET ITS GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION TARGETS FOR PASSENGER
VEHICLES.
FOR TWENTY TWENTY AND TWENTY
THIRTY FIVE AND RECENT STUDIES
SHOW THAT EMISSIONS FROM THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR CONTINUE
TO RISE.
AB ELEVEN FORTY TWO WILL ADDRESS
GAPS IN CALIFORNIA STRATEGIES TO
REDUCE TRANSPORTATION EMISSIONS.
BY REQUIRING REQUIRING REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION PLANS TO MEASURE
TRIPS MADE BY T. AND FEES AND
COMMUNITY SPECIFIC BARRIERS THAT
REDUCE UTILIZATION OF PUBLIC
TRANSIT.
AB ELEVEN FORTY TWO WILL ALSO
REQUIRE THE CPUC TO CONSIDER THE
LONG TERM PLANNING NEEDS AND
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITY STRATEGIES.
OF NPOS AND OTHER LOCAL AGENCIES
IN DETERMINING THE DATA
REPORTING TRIP REQUIREMENTS FOR
TEA AND FEES.
THESE REQUIREMENTS ARE ESSENTIAL
FOR REACHING CALIFORNIA'S LONG
TERM TRANSPORTATION IN CLINICAL
TH PLEASE VOTE YES ON AB ELEVEN
FORTY TWO THANK YOU [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
SENATORS MY NAME IS DAVE SNYDER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA BICYCLE
COALITION WE ARE VERY GRATEFUL
TO THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR
INTRODUCING THIS IF WE ARE GOING
TO GET A HANDLE ON GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS.
WE HAVE TO KEEP OUR EYE ON THE
BALL ON TECHNOLOGY AND ENERGY
EFFICIENCY IN BUILDINGS AND
STUFF LIKE THAT BUT WE SHOULD
FOCUS ON TRANSPORTATION BECAUSE
THAT'S WHERE WE'RE FAILING IN
THIS BILL HELPS US DO THAT.
A COUPLE OF A KEY POINTS FROM
OUR PERSPECTIVE ONE IS THE
REQUIREMENT TO MAKE SURE THAT
ACTED TRANSPORTATION AND IT IS
INCLUDED IN.
TRANSPORTATION PLANS ESPECIALLY
WITH ACCESS TO TRANSIT IN OUR
EXPERIENCE SOME OF THE M. HEROES
ALREADY DO THIS BUT SOME DON'T
THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT BILL TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT IT'S TAKEN
CARE OF IN ALL OF THE REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION PLANNING.
AND THEN THE DATA WITH REGARDS
TO TNC IS IS REALLY IMPORTANT WE
WE ARE ACTUALLY BULLISH ON TNC
IS IN GENERAL WE THINK THAT THE
THAT THEORETICALLY.
THE IDEA OF PEOPLE USING -- CARS
OCCASIONALLY I INSTEAD OF OWNING
THEI OWN CAR REDUCE VEHICLE
MILES TRAVELED BUT WE KNOW IN
FACT THAT'S NOT WE CAN DO IN THE
FUTURE.
TO HELP -- TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THAT POTENTIAL.
A BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE THE DATA
A REGIONAL -- AGENCIES WILL BE
ABLE -- TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THAT POTENTIAL AND AND IMPOSE --
AND AND WORK WITH -- EMPLOYEE
REGULATIONS AND WORK WITH THE
TNC IS. TO TO TO HELP THEM DO
WHAT THEY COULD DO TO REDUCE
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED IF THEY
HAVE THE DATA SO WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT ELEVEN FORTY TWO AND
URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF IT AS WELL
THANK YOU THIS -- SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT.
REMEMBER SECURE CREDIT WITH THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL ALSO HERE IN SUPPORT WE
THINK THIS LEVEL OF GRANULAR
INFORMATION IS REALLY IMPORTANT
FOR REGION'S TO BETTER PLAN
INVESTMENTS.
AND ALSO REALLY UNDERSTAND HOW
PEOPLE ARE TRAVELING THANK YOU
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE.
DO WE HAVE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
WE CAN MAKE SOME ROOM IN
FOURTEENTH PLACE.
MR TURN MEMBERS COURT IN JENSEN
A TECH MATT -- THANK YOU TO THE
AUTHOR FOR OUR CONTINUED
CONVERSATIONS -- WE DO REMAIN IN
OPPOSITION SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE
OF THE DATA PROVISIONS AND THIS
BILL WE ARE NOT -- ON THIS BILL
AT ALL -- BEFORE THE JUNE THIRD
AMENDMENTS WHEN AN BUT WE DO
HAVE -- SOME MAJOR CONCERNS WITH
THE PROBLEMATIC DATA SHARING
PROVISIONS -- THE RIGHT SURE
INDUSTRY ENABLES MOBILITY FOR
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS WITHIN
THESE PLATFORMS DATA -- IS DATA
THAT WE UNDERSTAND CAN BE USEFUL
FOR PLANNING PURPOSES HOWEVER
THE USES OF THAT MUST BE
BALANCED WITH SIGNIFICANT RISKS
CREATED BY THE SHARING OF GEO
LOCATION AND MOVEMENT DATA.
OF PASSENGERS AND DRIVERS
WITHOUT ADEQUATE PROTECTIONS THE
CURRENT LANGUAGE OF THE BILL
DOES NOT ADDRESS THESE RISKS
GIVEN THE NATURE AND SCOPE OF
THE DATA THAT'S REQUIRED TO BE
SHARED WITHOUT ANY PRE
ESTABLISHED PRIVACY SAFEGUARDS --
FURTHER THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE
THE CPUC TO INTERRUPT IN UNDER
CUT A MULTI YEAR RULE MAKING
PROCESS RELATED TO TNC DATA
SHARING.
AND SEVERAL ENTITIES THAT ARE
ACTUALLY INCLUDED IN THE
LANGUAGE OF THIS BILL CITIES
PLANNING AGENCIES RESEARCH
ORGANIZATIONS ARE PARTIES TO
THOSE PROCEEDINGS.
THESE ENTITIES HAVE STATED THEIR
DEMANDS AND THEIR COMMENTS FILED
PURSUANT TO THIS PROCEEDING AND
OTHER STATEMENTS FOR DETAILED
TRIP DATA.
AND A SHOWN THERE FAR REACHING
INTENT FOR HOW THEY PLAN TO USE
THE DATA INCLUDING TO MONETIZE
TNC DATA.
THIS BILL STATES THAT THERE IS A
PUBLIC INTEREST THAT TNC SHARE
DETAILED TRIP DATA WITH VARIOUS
STATE AND LOCAL ENTITIES AND AN
UNDEFINED OTHER RELEVANT PARTIES
FOR A PURPOSE.
THAT IS ALSO NOT CLEARLY DEFINED
THE BILL DOES NOT SPECIFY WHO
THE RECIPIENTS OF THE DATA ARE
POTENTIALLY ALLOWING ANYONE TO
CLAIM ACCESS TO HIGHLY SENSITIVE
INFORMATION INCLUDING DETAILED
ORIGIN AND DESTINATION
INFORMATION.
TIME STAMPS AND MILES TRAVEL
THIS AGGREGATED DETAILED TRIP
DATA COULD POTENTIALLY BE USED
TO ESTABLISH AN INDIVIDUAL'S
TRAVEL PATTERNS AND POTENTIALLY
WERE FEEL SENSITIVE INFORMATION.
LET'S SEE YOU YOU SEE WE DO
BELIEVE WILL ISSUE A PROPOSED
DECISION ON THE SCOPE OF TNC
DATA SHARING SHORTLY.
WHICH WERE CONSIDERED
INCORPORATED THE PERSPECTIVES OF
MANY STAKEHOLDERS AND THIS
LEGISLATION SHOULD NOT INTERFERE
WITH THAT PROCESS AND THE OLD TO
MAKE DECISION -- FINALLY JUST
VERY QUICKLY CITIES ARE NOT HELD
TO THE SAME STANDARDS AS
SECURITY AND PRIVACY STANDARDS
WRIST RESPECTIVE WHO DATA CAN BE
SHARED WITH AND HOW IT CAN BE
USED AND THEREFORE THE BILL.
AS CURRENTLY WRITTEN CREATE
SIGNIFICANT RISKS TO TNC IS USER
PRIVACY AND SECURITY --
CURRENTLY THE BILL STATES THAT
RELEVANT DATA SHARING PROTOCOLS
WILL BE USED TO PROTECT USER
PRIVACY BUT FAILS TO SPECIFY
WHAT THOSE PROTOCOLS ARE.
HOW THEY WILL PROTECT THE
SENSITIVE DATA FROM BEING
MISUSED AND HOW THEY WILL BE
CONSISTENT WITH OTHER PRIVACY
POLICIES THAT THIS LEGISLATURE
HAS PASSED?
AND TO BE CLEAR TRANSPORTATION
PLANNING AND SUSTAINABILITY
GOALS OF CALIFORNIA OUR GOALS
THAT WE SHARE WE'VE WORKED WITH
THIS LEGISLATURE TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE PASSED LEGISLATION TO
SUPPORT THOSE GOALS AND FOR THE
DATA SHARING THAT -- IS NEEDED
FOR THOSE GOALS BUT
UNFORTUNATELY GIVEN THE BILLING
PRINT TODAY -- AND THERE ARE
CONTINUED CONVERSATIONS GOING ON
AT THE AUTHOR WE DID -- PROVIDE
SOME AMENDMENTS BUT AS CURRENTLY
IN PRINT TODAY WE HAVE
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS AND REMAIN
OPPOSED.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS LEAH SO WITH OUR WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE HELP CHAMBERS MEMBERS
UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE OF
WORKING WITH THE PC AND WITH
LEGISLATURE ON A SOLUTION THAT
HELPS THE PC AND MUNICIPALITIES
BILL DATA DRIVEN REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION PLANS.
AND OUR MEMBERS ARE COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR OF POTENTIAL AMENDMENTS
HOWEVER AS CURRENTLY DRAFTED THE
BILL DOES HAVE THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES LAID OUT WHAT MY
COLLEAGUE AT TECHNION.
IN ORDER TO ACCOMPLISH THE
INTENT OF THIS BILL WITHOUT FOR
IN THE PRIVACY OF USERS AND
WITHOUT INCREASING OPERATIONAL
DEMANDS ON THE PC AND INDUSTRY.
IT'S CRITICAL TO FIRST IDENTIFY
WHICH MUNICIPAL POLICIES THAT
BENEFIT FROM TNC DATA AND FROM
THERE ASSESS HOW WHAT AND WHEN
DATA COULD BE DISTRIBUTED TO THE
MUNICIPALITY IS.
GIVING SO IN THIS MANNER WOULD
ENSURE THAT THE GOALS OF THE
MUNICIPALITIES CAN BE MET WILL
ALSO MITIGATING THE REST THAT
STEM FROM DATA SHARING WITHOUT
ADEQUATE SAFEGUARDS.
THE YEARS LONG RULE MAKING
UNDERTAKEN BY THE PC REPRESENTS
THE CHALLENGE OF DETERMINING
THIS FOR SINGLE AGENCY.
WITHOUT THE SAME FEAR OF CARE
THE LEGISLATURE CAN RISK
UNDERMINE THE PROCESS AND
EXPRESSING THE PC IN THE BELLY
OPERATORS TO AN ENDLESS STREAM
ON ACCORDING TO DATA REQUEST.
THEY CAN POTENTIALLY RESULT IN A
SUBSTANTIAL VOLUME A SENSITIVE
DATA BEING DISCLOSED BECAUSE THE
BILL DOES STILL CONTAIN THESE
AMBIGUITIES AROUND THE
DEFINITIONS LAID OUT BY MY
COLLEAGUE AT TECH NET.
AND HOW WILL BE SHARED WE
STRONGLY ENCOURAGE FILLING THE
GAPS IN THIS BILL FOR THESE
REASONS AND OTHERS CAL TIMBER
CONTINUES TO BE OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL.
WHO UNDER ONE ELSE A POSITION?
CLUB CD CALIFORNIA ADVISERS HERE
WE HAVE UBER -- WE ALSO REMAIN
OPPOSED THE REASONS STATED THANK
YOU.
NO ONE ELSE [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
CENTER RUBIO THANK YOU.
WELL FIRST FIVE ONE I THINK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
I THINK THAT HAVING A REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION PLAN IS.
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO TOLD OUR
GOALS AS THE STATE CITY TO CITY
LEADERS AND ALSO STATE LEADERS
BUT ONE OF MY CONCERNS AND AND
AGAIN I I REALLY DO LIKE THIS
BILL BUT YOU KNOW I JUST WANNA
MAKE GIVE YOU THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE CONCERNS.
AS IT PERTAINS TO A SENSITIVE
DATA INFORMATION AND HOW IT'S
CHAIRED CAN YOU.
SPEAK TO THAT PLEASE THANK YOU
SENATOR I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
QUESTION SO THE BILL DOES NOT
REQUIRE THE SHARING OF DATA DOES
NOT DICTATE HOW THE DATE IS
GONNA BE SURE TO DOESN'T DICTATE
WHAT DATA WILL BE SHARED.
IT JUST GIVES A LITTLE BIT MORE
PARAMETERS SIX TWO C. P. YOU SEE
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT THE NEEDS OF LOCAL
AGENCIES.
SO THE CPUC CERTAINLY WITHIN
THEIR HEARING WILL TAKE ALL OF
THESE PRIVACY TO CONCERNS INTO
ACCOUNT AND THEN LIMIT THE DATA
THAT SHARED THROUGH THEIR
PROCESS THE BILL DOESN'T SAY TO
SEE IF YOU SEE.
YOU MUST REQUIRE UBER TO GIVE
RAW DATA TO THE AGENCIES IT
DOESN'T SPECIFY THE LEVEL OF
SPECIFICITY THAT'S GIVEN IN FACT
WE FULLY WOULD WANT A C. P. YOU
SEE TO MAKE SURE THAT PRIVACY IS
TAKEN INTO ACCOUNT -- BUT WE ARE
TRYING TO TELL THEM THOUGH TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE NEEDS OF THE
AGENCIES ARE TAKEN INTO ACCOUNT
WHEN YOU SET THESE RULES.
WE HAVE BEEN MONITORING THE
ONGOING HEARINGS THAT THEY'VE
BEEN HAVING AND THEIR PROCESS
AND WE FEEL THAT THEY'RE NOT
TAKING THE AGENCIES NEEDS ARE
FOR PLANNING INTO ACCOUNT AND
NOT.
AND WE'RE JUST TELLING THEM TO
PRIORITIZE THAT WE'RE CERTAINLY
HAPPY TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON
AMENDMENTS THAT WOULD MAKE IT
CLEAR THAT WE'RE NOT TRYING TO
GET THEM TO TRUMP CALIFORNIA LAW.
WHEN IT COMES TO PRIVACY OR TO
GIVE ANY DATA THAT SO SENSITIVE
THAT WOULD -- BE OUTSIDE OF
CALIFORNIA LAW WE WE ABSOLUTELY
RESPECT THE PRIVACY WORK THAT'S
BEEN DONE THAT'S BEEN PASSED
LAST YEAR AND WE WOULD FULLY
EXPECT THE CPUC.
TERMINATION SO CERTAINLY THEY'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO DO A BALANCE
AND LET ME ALSO SAY -- GLENDALE
FOR INSTANCE OWNS ALL POWER
COMPANY THEY KNOW EXACTLY WHEN
ALL OF THEIR USERS ARE WATCHING
TELEVISION OR RUNNING THEIR POOL
PUMP TO THEIR SMART METER
PROGRAM CITIES ARE ABSOLUTELY.
RIGHT NOW -- HAVE A LOT OF DATA
THAT ABOUT THEIR CITIZENS -- AT
THEIR FINGERTIPS AND I DO THINK
THAT WE NEEDBETTER REGULATIONS
TO MAKE SURE THAT CITIES --
CONTROL THAT DATA THAT THEY HAVE
THE ABSOLUTE BEST ARMED ANTI --
PIRACY AN ANTI HACKING
TECHNOLOGY AT THEIR FINGERTIPS
WE SHOULD MAKE SURE THAT THAT
HAPPENS WE SHOULD ALSO HAVE
PARAMETERS ON HOW CITIES ARE
ABLE TO USE DATA THE SAME WAY
THAT WE SHOULD FOR THE TECH
INDUSTRY.
BUT THAT'S A DIFFERENT
CONVERSATION THAT DOESN' THAT
EXTEND TO THE POINT THAT WE
SHOULD NEVER GIVE THEM DATA OR
ALLOW THEM TO COLLECTED OR USED
DATA I THINK THEY'RE REALLY TWO
DIFFERENT ISSUES THAT ARE
GETTING CONFUSED HERE.
IF THEY'RE WORRIED THAT CITIES
DON'T HAVE ADEQUATE A FIRE WALLS
ON THEIR SERVERS THAT'S A
CONVERSATION THAT WE HAVE THE
ANSWER TO THAT IS NOT TO SAY
WILL DON'T GIVE THEM ANY DAY
THAT THEY NEED TO RUN THEIR
CITIES -- THE SO I I THINK THAT
THAT'S BEING A LITTLE BIT
COMPLETED BUT I ALSO DON'T WANT
CITIES TO HAVE DATA THAT THEY
DON'T NEED AND THATTHEY CAN USE
TO TRACK THEIR CITIZENS WE'RE
NOT TRYING TO REQUIRE THAT AND
WE CAN CERTAINLY MAKE THAT CLEAR
IN THE BILL.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME IF PEOPLE
ARE USING TNC IS IF THEY'RE
USING UBER TO GET TO A CERTAIN
LOCATION CONSISTENTLY CITIES
NEED TO KNOW THAT BECAUSE THEY
MAY WANT TO RUN A BUS TO THAT
LOCATION.
OR THEY MAY WANT TO HAVE MORE
FREQUENT DREAM SERVICE TO THAT
IN PERMITTED THAT LOCATION IF
THEY DON'T KNOW WHEN PEOPLE ARE
TAKING RIDE SHARING AND WHEN AND
WHERE THEY'RE TAKING IT.
THEY CANNOT PLAN THEIR OWN
TRANSIT SO SOMEWHERE BETWEEN
THEIR CONCERNS AND MAKING SURE
THAT P. C. P. YOU SEE TAKES THAT.
GOAL SERIOUSLY IS WHERE THIS
BILL IS YOU KNOW ATTEMPTING TO
LAND AND WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE
THE CONVERSATION WITH UBER AND
WHAT TECH NET TO ADDRESS THEIR
CONCERNS AND BUT I DON'T THINK
THAT THAT SHOULD STOP.
US FROM MAKING SURE THAT OUR
PUBLIC AGENCIES GET THE
INFORMATION THAT THEY NEED FROM
FROM COMPANIES THAT ARE
OPERATING WITHIN THEIR
BOUNDARIES.
WHAT THANK YOU SO BAD -- THAT
WAS NOT AN ISSUE FOR ME BUT
HEARING THE CONCERNS OF THE
OPPOSITION I REALLY.
DO APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING IT
FORWARD -- YOU KNOW AS YOU
MENTIONED WE PASS LOSS LAST YEAR
AS A PERTAINS TO PROTECTING
SENSITIVE DATA BUT WHAT I'M
HEARING IS YOUR OPEN AND WILLING
TO WORK WITH THEM TO CONTINUE TO
ENSURE THAT.
THERE'S CLEAR DATA I'M SORRY
YOUR LANGUAGE US TO THE
PROTECTION OF PEOPLE'S
INFORMATION.
AND WITHOUT I'M SATISFIED THANK
YOU THANK YOU SENATOR
[inaudible]
STERN.
THEY MISTER.
THANK YOU SO MEMBER FIRMING IN
THIS FOR NAY PRECIADO THAT'S A
HELPFUL EXCHANGE -- I KNOW WE'RE
GONNA HEAR THIS IN JUDICIAL Và
GETS OUT TODAY SO -- I THINK THE
PRIVACY ISSUES RESOLVABLE I
THINK THERE'S A WAY TO HANDLE
THAT I I DO AGREE THAT.
WHAT WHAT IS DETAILED TRIP
INFORMATION THAT FEELS OPEN
ENDED DOESN'T CONCERN ABOUT
OTHER RELEVANT PARTIES LIKE
[inaudible]
WHO -- SO WANTED BE REFINED.
MY I WANT TO TRY TO SOLVE THE
SAME PROBLEM THAT YOU'RE LOOKING
AT HERE WHICH IS ACTUALLY HAD TO
DO ACCURATE.
TRANSPORTATION PLANNING.
AND THE CONCERN IS IF YOU HAVE.
I THINK IT'S WHAT 2% OF TRIPS
ARE SO IN AT LEAST IN OUR AREA
IN THE LA AREA. TWO OR 3% LIKE
ARE WE GET A FULL PICTURE.
OUT OF THIS BILL.
FROM JUST LOOKING AT RIDE
SHARING AND I THIS MAY SOUND
OVERLY INVASIVE BUT WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT THE 98% OF THE REST OF
THE CARS ARE DOING IN LA.
OR THE TRUCKS RIGHT I THINK OF
BIG RIGS RUNNING UP THE I FIVE
RUNS AND TENDER.
YOU KNOW LIKE WHOSE WOULD
COMMUTE TIME TO TRY TO DO THIS
TRANSPORTATION MODELING WE DO TO
FOR A VALLEY TRANSIT PATTERNS
[inaudible]
SO WITHOUT.
THAT FULL DATA SET THEN HOW DOES
THIS.
WORK I KNOW YOU'RE THINKING
FIRST MY LAST MILES OR TO
TRANSIT BASED WANTED.
ENGAGE ON THAT ONE THANK YOU
KNOW IT'S A GREAT QUESTION SO
FIRST OF ALL THE DATA IS NOW
SHOWING THAT IN MAJOR CITIES TNC
IS OUR ACCOUNTING FOR UP 215% OF
INTEREST CITY TRIPS.
SO IN SOME AREAS IT MIGHT BE 2%
BUT IF YOU'RE IN DOWNTOWN LOS
ANGELES IT COULD MAYBE EVEN BE
HIGHER THAN 15%.
SO -- IT'S IMPORTANT THAT CITIES
UNDERSTAND THAT AND I I AGREE OF
COURSE YOU WANT TO WERE ALL THE
CARS ARE GOING BUT TNC USER FOR
FILLING A VERY SPECIFIC KIND OF
NEAT I THINK.
YOU KNOW THERE TEND TO BE GOING
AND THAT'S THAT'S WHY IT'S
INTERESTING TO KNOW THAT IN SOME
PLACES A 50% IN SOME PLACES IT'S
2%.
SO WHAT IS THE DIFFERENCE -- AND
IT ARE THEY FOR FILLING THE
FIRST MILE LAST MILE FUNCTION
ARE THEY FOR FILLINGS --
FUNCTIONS ABOUT CERTAIN TYPES OF
SPECIAL EVENTS WERE PARKING IS
DIFFICULT.
CITIES NEED TO UNDERSTAND WHY
PEOPLE ARE TAKING THEM AND WHERE
AND HOW THEY FIT IN WITH TRANSIT
SO YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT
THERE'S SOME ON ANSWER QUESTIONS
HERE BECAUSE THE CITIES DON'T
HAVE ALWAYSTHE DATA THAT THEY
NEED TO REALLY BE ARE.
ABLE TO HAVE THAT FULL PICTURE
BUT DO YOU THINK I MEAN ARE YOU
OPEN.
TO I DON'T EVEN KNOW IF I WANT
THIS AMENDMENT FRANKLY BUT BUT
WE SHOULD KNOW ABOUT ALL VEHICLE
TRIPS.
IF IF WE'RE GOING TO GO DOWN
THIS ROAD WE SHOULD KNOW WHERE
EVERYONE'S DRIVING NOT JUST
SHARED VEHICLE.
THAT THAT'S THE BIG CONCERN.
YEAH.
IF TEAM FIRST AS A I WANT TO
KNOW WHERE THE 85% OF OTHERS A
FOR GOING TO HAVE ACCURATE
MODELING FOR TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM.
I THINK THAT A LOT OF THE MORE
SOPHISTICATED TNC CERTAINLY KNOW
THINGS LIKE THE AMOUNT OF
TRAFFIC ON THE HIGHWAY -- THEY
HAVE A GENERAL IDEA OF WHERE
THEY HAVE MORE CONGESTION WHERE
PEOPLE ARE DRIVING MORE TO JOB
CENTERS.
ARE FOR INSTANCE -- SO I THINK
THAT THAT'S YOU KNOW THE DAY
THEY DO NEED TO HAVE THAT DATA
BUT WITHOUT KNOWING HOW WHICH
NUMBERS OF THOSE CARS ARE TNC
USE THEIR ALSO MISSING A REALLY
IMPORTANT PART OF THE PICTURE
AND THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL IS
JUST IS TRYING TO UNDERSTAND.
YEAH I JUST WANT TO POINT OUT I
KNOW THE METROPOLITAN PLANNING
ORGANIZATIONS A NUMBER OF FOR
CERTAINLY REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION EIGHT AGENCIES.
ALREADY HAVE THIS IN FROM A LOT
OF THIS INFORMATION -- BECAUSE
OF FAST TRACK AND THEY ALREADY
HAVE STANDARDS AROUND THAT
PRIVACY STANDARDS.
I DON'T THINK THIS IS REALLY
ANYTHING NEW.
FROM THAT STANDPOINT IT JUST
INCREASES THE DATA SETS AND YOU
KNOW I I I REALLY DO BELIEVE
THAT -- THEY CAN YOU CAN PUT THE
THAT TRANSPARENCY OR THE PRIVACY.
YOU KNOW POLICIES IN HERE TO
PROTECT.
YEAH SAID TO THE DATA
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I JUST WANTED TO COME
IF I COULD JUST BRIEFLY I I
THINK THERE IS A PLACE WHERE YOU
CAN.
GET THAT WILL RESOLVE SOME OF
THE ISSUES IN TERMS OF PRIVACY
AND TO GET TO THAT SWEET SPOT SO
HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE BILL WITH
FORD.
BUT I THINK HOPEFULLY IF IT
DOESN'T GET THEIR THEM WE MAY
HAVE A PROBLEM WITH THE AND I
THINK JUST.
TO THE IT'S AN IMPORTANT
CONSIDERATION THAT WE REALLY GET
THE DATA -- BUT THIS IS JUST THE
BEGINNING BECAUSE I THINK IF
IT'S 15% WILL LOOK AT THE 85%
AND TRYING. TO TO ACCOMPLISH THE
ACCESSING THAT AN UNDERSTANDING
THOSE TRAVEL MODELS THAT -- IN
DOING THAT THERE'S THEIR PRIVACY
CONCERNS ISSUE THIS COULD BE A
WAS A PRECEDENT SETTING BUT IT
COULD BE A MODEL THAT COULD BE
USED FOR OTHER FORMS AS WELL SO
I WITH.
BICYCLES OR SCOOTERS OR
SOMETHING ELSE SO HOPEFULLY WE
CAN GET THERE.
YOU KNOW I I RAN A SIMILAR BILL
A FEW YEARS BACK BECAUSE THERE
WERE -- SOME EXAMPLES OUT THERE
IN THE COMMUNITY.
THAT SHOWED THAT CERTAIN DURING
CERTAIN EVENTS THE WORD JUSTICE --
HUGE GROWTH.
LIKE IN ONE OF AND ALL OF A
SUDDEN THEY THEY THEY FLOOD AN
AREA WITH VEHICLES.
MORE THAN THAT EVENT ACTUALLY
NEEDS.
AND AND NORMALLY HISTORICALLY
CITIES HAVE ALWAYS -- DESIGN
THEIR TRANSPORTATION SYSTEMS
AROUND HOW MANY -- FOR HIGHER
VEHICLES THERE ARE AROUND HOW
MANY TRAINS AND BUSES.
AND IN THIS NEW ENVIRONMENT YOU
CAN KIND OF FLOOD THE MARKET
JUST BY SOMEBODY SIGN UP AND
SAYING I'M GONNA WORK THE SUPER
FOR ME TO WORK THE THIS SPECIFIC
FAIR.
AND THERE IS A DELUSION OF
AUTOMOBILE USE MANY TIMES THOSE
[inaudible]
THOSE -- THE USERS OF THOSE ARE
MORE OF THOSE THE SERVER
PROVIDERS OF THE SERVICES.
CAN'T FIND ANY CUSTOMERS BIRTH
THROUGHOUT THEIR WORK IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD.
AND IT CREATES A FLOOD OF OF
TRAFFIC.
AND OF EMISSIONS AND AND WE GOT
WENT OVER YEARS -- ALSO --
TALKING ABOUT HOW -- THE THE
INDUSTRY WAS GONNA ELECTRIFY AND
CREATE KIND OF ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES.
THERE'S IT'S THIS DATA A I THINK
COULD BE EASILY DERIVED BY THE
THE TRIPS THAT ARE THAT ARE ALL --
REPORTED -- ELECTRONICALLY.
ALL THIS INFORMATION IS COMPILED
IN A AND IN A THE ALL THE DATA
IS AVAILABLE TO THE COMPANY
BECAUSETHAT'S HOW THEY
COMPETENT EMPLOYEES BASED ON THE
TRIPS.
EVEN PRIOR TO THAT -- OLD
TRANSPORTATION COMPANIES WERE
REQUIRED TO MAINTAIN -- TRIP
SHEETS.
SO ALL THE ALL THE DATA IS THERE
IT'S JUST A MATTER OF NEEDED
INTO -- A FORM THAT CAN BE.
YOU KNOW WERE PROVIDED.
FOR WITH THE HOPE OF PROVIDING
THE NUMBER OF TRIPS THAT ARE OUT
THERE BEING GENERATED EITHER BY
EVENTS.
AND THIS IS SOMETHING THAT IS
GOING TO BE VERY IMPORTANT. TO
OUR OUR CLIMATE GOALS I THINK
THE INDUSTRY'S ARGUED THAT THEY
HELP SAVE TRIPS -- THEY'RE
SAYING THAT MAYBE BECAUSE THEY
HAVE THAT INFORMATION AVAILABLE
TO THEM IF IT IS THEY SHOULD
PROVIDE AND AND MAKE THAT THAT
INFORMATION.
AVAILABLE TO OUR PUBLIC AGENCIES --
TO MAYBE -- CONFIRM THAT CLAIM.
IF IF THEY ARE SAYING IT MUST BE
BECAUSE IT MUST BE TRUE.
AND IF IT'S TRUE IS BECAUSE
BASED ON DATA AND IF THEY HAVE
THE DATA PROVIDED.
CAN BE PROVIDE I THINK IT'LL BE.
IMPORTANT AND IT WOULD.
AT LEAST GIVE PEOPLE AN IDEA OF
WHAT'S HAPPENING ON OUR STREETS --
ANYONE ELSE -- DID YOU WANNA
MAKE ANY CLOSING COMMENTS TO WE
HAVE A MOTION.
ARE WE HAVE A MOTION.
SHOULD THE ROBUST DISCUSSION I
THINK YOU ALL -- YOU KNOW
CLEARLY APPRECIATE THE GOALS OF
THE BILL AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION TO GET
THIS IN THE RIGHT PLACE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
CLERK FISCAL ROW.
YOU PASSAGE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
WEST SO I WAS SO I MORE LOCK
BRADFORD.
BEDFORD I CHIANG DODD HI DODD
AYE HERTZBERG HILL.
HILL AYE MCGUIRE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SKINNER STERN
[inaudible]
STONE.
STONE NO WIENER [inaudible] FIVE
ONE OKAY WE WILL -- KEEP THE
ROLE OF THE ABSENT MEMBERS WILL
COME OVER TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DENTAL DONALD THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WITH [inaudible]
HE DOES.
WE'LL LOOK AT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
AND I'D LIKE TO START OFF BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITMENTS AND
THANK YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR
WORKING.
WITH ME ON THIS BILL I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT AB. THIRTEEN
SIXTY TWO WHICH IS IT WOULD --
JAZZ PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED.
WOULD REQUIRE THE P. YOU SEE TO
OLLECT AND MAKE PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE ON THEIR WEBSITE
INFORMATION ON THE RATES AND
PROGRAMS OFFERED BY LOAD SERVING.
ENTITIES.
AFFORDABILITY RELIABILITY AND D.
CARBONIZATION ARE THE CORE
PRINCIPLES OF CALIFORNIA'S
ENERGY POLICY.
DECADES OF LEGISLATIVE AND
REGULATORY ACTIONS HAVE ADJUSTED
MARKETS AND ESTABLISH PROGRAMS
TO ADVANCE THESE GOALS.
AT THE SAME TIME NEW LOW SERVING
ENTITIES LIKE COMMUNITY CHOICE
ACTAGGREGATORS HAVE GIVEN RATE
PAYERS MORE OPTIONS FOR ENERGY
DELIVERY.
THAN EVER BEFORE.
IN ORDER TO FACILITATE THIS
ROBUST AND COMPETITIVE MARKET
CUSTOMERS NEED FULL ACCESS TO
ACCURATE PRICING INFORMATION.
AND OTHER PROGRAM OFFERINGS.
AB THIRTEEN SIXTY TWO AS
PROPOSED TO BE OMITTED.
WILL PROVIDE THIS INFORMATION BY
REQUIRING THE PC TO POST ON
THEIR WEBSITE.
ACCURATE AND NON BIASED
INFORMATION CONCERNING A LOAD
SERVING AND HE'S ELECTRICITY
RATES AND ENERGY.
PORTFOLIO.
THIS WILL ENSURE -- GREATER
CONSUMER PROTECTION AND
TRANSPARENCY OF ALL LIKE TRICITY
RATES AND PRODUCTS THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I BELIEVE I HAD I
DO HAVE SOME WITNESSES HERE SURE
THANK YOU.
DO WE HAVE SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT
OR SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION IF
YOU'D COME FORWARD.
STRUCTURE MEMBERS MIKE MONEY
GOING TO BE HAVE THE COALITION
OF CALIFORNIA UTILITY EMPLOYEES
IN SUPPORT. TEN MEMBERS REBEKAH
LEE ON THE HAVE A SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON WOULD BELIEVE
THIS BILL WOULD HELP CUSTOMERS
MAKE MORE INFORMED DECISIONS
WITH REGARDS TO THEIR SERVICE
PROVIDERS THANK YOU.
ARE TONIGHT [inaudible]
ANYONE OPPOSITION.
MEMBERS ANYTHING.
WE HAVE THIS REAL QUICK IF I MAY.
WELL YOU KNOW I KNOW WE HAD A
COUPLE OF INFORMATIONAL HEARINGS
IN THE PAST AND I THINK THE ONE
OF THE MOST IMPORTANT THINGS
THAT CAME OUT OF THOSE --
HEARINGS WAS THE NEED FOR A
CENTRALIZED PLACE WHERE.
PEOPLE CAN GATHER A DATA RIGHT
NOW WITH THAT NEW -- EVERYDAY.
THEN YOU SYSTEMS COMING OUT LIKE
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
RATE PAYERS ABLE TO TO HAVE
INFORMATION AT THEIR FINGERTIPS
MAKE SURE IT'S ACCURATE UNBIASED.
AND SAID SOMETHING THAT I WAS
CONSIDERING -- ACTUALLY --
COOPER RAIN SO IF I MAY IN THE
FUTURE YOU MAY ASK ME ASK WATER
THANK YOU.
ABSOLUTELY LOVE THAT YES.
VERY WELL WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR BRADFORD.
YES WE DO [inaudible]
THE CLICK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
HE PASSES AMEND.
THE PASS IS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WES SO.
WHY WAS SO I MORE LACK BRADFORD?
BRADFORD AYE CHAIN DODD.
DODD AYE HERTZBERG HILL.
HILL AYE MCGUIRE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SKINNER STERN.
STERN ICE DOWN STONE AYE WIENER.
FANTASTIC THE BILL HAS ENOUGH
VOTES TO GET OUT OF OPAL IN ON
NOT ON ON CALL FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
THANK YOU -- CAN I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE HAVE A MOTION ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR FOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
AB TEN SEVENTY TWO PATTERSON AB
FIFTEEN THIRTEN HOLDEN.
WEST SO FIVE WAS SO I AM
MOORLACH BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I CHIANG DODD.
DODD AYE HERTZBERG HILL.
HILL AYE MCGUIRE RUBIO MCGUIRE
AYE RUBIO.
ALL EYES SKINNER.
STERN.
STERN AYE DOWN.
DOWN AYE WIENER.
WILL MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER NINE
A. B. FIFTEEN EIGHTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND SENATORS --
FIRST I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH MY
OFFICE.
AND FOR THE THOUGHTFUL ANALYSIS
OF BE ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENT ON
PAGE SEVEN OF THE ANALYSIS.
SO WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE
IS.
LOAD SERVING ENTITIES -- BY AND
LARGE ARE -- GOING TO PAY WELL
THE POINT OF THE BILL IS FOR
THEM TO PAY THE INDIRECT COSTS.
THAT THEIR PORTFOLIOS IMPOSE ON
THE ELECTRIC SYSTEMS.
OF WHICH IS TO SEND UP TO AND
WHAT WE WOULD DO IS SEND A PRICE
SIGNAL THAT WILL ENCOURAGE A
WELL BALANCED PORTFOLIO TO SERVE
CUSTOMER LOAD.
LOAD SERVING ENTITIES -- MAY NOT
MATCH THEIR ENERGY PURCHASES TO
THEIR CUSTOMER LOAD PROFILES.
LEAVING THE CALIFORNIA
INDEPENDENT SYSTEM OPERATOR WITH
RESPONSIBILITY OF ENSURING THAT
SUFFICIENT SISTER RESOURCES ARE
AVAILABLE.
THE SERVER LOAD.
SO WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IS
IF THE LOAD SERVING AND A D..
I. IS SHORT ON ENERGY AT SOME
PARTICULAR DAY OR TIME.
THAT THE I. SL WILL GO TO THE
MARKET AND IT WILL.
CURE WHATEVER ENERGY IS NEEDED
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE DON'T HAVE
BLACKOUTS AS WE DID IN.
TWO THOUSAND TWO THOUSAND ONE OF
BY AND LARGE THAT ENERGY WHICH
WILL BE PURCHASED WILL COME --
FROM NATURAL GAS AND IT'LL
PROBABLY COME FROM OUT OF STATE.
HELLO POTENTIALLY COULD COME
FROM THE IN STATE AS WELL.
COULD EVEN COME FROM COAL
RESOURCES -- BECAUSE WE'RE NOT
GOING TO ALLOW ANY BLACKOUTS.
THE PROBLEM IS THAT WHEN YOU
PURCHASE THIS ENERGY ON THE SPOT
MARKET CAN BE EXTREMELY
EXPENSIVE.
AND WHAT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE IS
THAT.
THOSE WHO BECAUSE THE SYSTEM. TO
HAVE TO PAY FOR VERY EXPENSIVE
ENERGY ON THE SPOT MARKET ALSO
VERY THE BEAR THE COSTS.
RIGHT NOW THOSE COSTS ARE SIMPLY
ALLOCATED BASED UPON LOW CHAIR
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
ACTUAL ENTITY WHICH DEMANDED
THOSE COSTS -- WOULD IN FACT.
OF PAY FOR THOSE COSTS SO IT
GIVES A CRISIS PRICE SIGNAL TO
THE MARKET -- THE ALTERNATIVE IS
TO MAKE SURE THAT YOUR LOAD
SERVING ENERGY HAS.
ALTERNATIVES SUCH AS STORAGE ARE
OR SOME OTHER SORT OF BACK UP
POWER -- BATTERIES -- PUMP HYDRO
ET CETERA [inaudible]
SO.
AB F. FIFTEEN EIGHTY FOUR WITH
INSURE THAT LOAD SERVING
ENERGIES PAY THEIR SHARE THE
INDIRECT COSTS.
WITH ME TODAY IS NANCY RAIDER
WITH CALIFORNIA WIND ENERGY
ASSOCIATION AVAILABLE TO AND
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE ARE YOU ACCEPTIG A
MEMBER ABSOLUTELY OKAY VERY GOOD
AMENDMENT.
THANK YOU DID WAS DIDN'T DO YOU
WANT TO SPEAK IN FAVOR ANYONE.
I JUST -- SPEAKERS IN FAVOR FOR
MELISSA CORTES ROTH ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA WIND ENERGY
ASSOCIATION WHERE THE SPONSORS
OF THE BILL WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
CHAIRMAN THERE'S REBEKAH LEVY ON
BEHALF THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
EDISON WE BELIEVE THIS MEASURE
WILL HELP ALL PROVIDERS MAKE
MORE BALANCE PROCUREMENT CHOICES
TO CONTRIBUTE TO THE OVER HEALTH
OVERALL HEALTH OF THE GREAT TO
ENSURE RELIABILITY OR SHOULD I
VOTE THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING NOW DROWNED ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA BIOMASS
ENERGY ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT.
YOUR CHAIR MEMBERS MIGHT WANT TO
GOING TO BE HALF THE COALITION
CALIFORNIA UTILITY EMPLOYEES IN
SUPPORT.
IT'S NOT HERNANDEZ A BEHALF THE
UTILITY REFORM NETWORK OR TURN
IN SUPPORT.
GOT SOME GOOD SUPPORTERS THERE --
ANY OPPOSITION ON THE BILL
[inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
A MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF MY
NAME IS SHANNON EDDIE I'M
REPRESENTING THE LARGE SCALE
SOLAR ASSOCIATION TODAY.
IN OPPOSITION TO FIFTEEN EIGHTY
FOUR I WANT TO TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT OUR CONCERNS -- THIS BILL
WOULD FORCE THE PC TO IMPLEMENT
AN APPROACH THAT CAL WE A HAS
PROPOSED MULTIPLE TIMES IN THAT
THE PC HAS REJECTED EACH TIME
PRETTY MUCH OUT OF HAND.
IN THE SIMPLEST TERMS IT WOULD
PENALIZE THE ELLIS'S THAT HAVE A
LARGER SOLAR IN INTERMITTENCY
PORTFOLIO.
BY SHIFTING AN EXTRA COST BURDEN
TO THEM VIA THE ARE A PROGRAM.
THE PREMISE BEHIND THE BILL IS
THAT CILLER CREATES INTEGRATION
PROBLEMS THAT SHOULD BE REMEDIED
BY CHANGING HOW ARE A IS PAID.
FOR WHEN IN REALITY WHAT WE'RE
SEEING IS IN SO MUCH AS A
PROBLEM AS A TRANSITION IN THE
MARKET AND THAT DESERVES MUCH
MORE THOUGHT THAN ON WHAT A
CURSORY.
QUICK CHANGE TO THE ARE A
PROGRAM WOULD MERIT.
WE HAVE FOUR CONCERNS ABOUT THE
BILL THAT I WANT TO BREAK DOWN
FIRST IT WOULD UNNECESSARILY
COMPLICATE BOTH THE I. R. P. AND
THE ARE YOU PROGRAM.
IT WOULD DISTRACT THE PC STAFF
AWAY FROM THEIR PRIORITIES IT
WOULD DISINCENTIVE EYES ELLIS
SEES FROM FROM OVER PROCURING
WIND AND SOLAR.
AT A TIME WHEN OVER BUILDING
BOTH IS BEGINNING TO EMERGE --
AS A KEY SOLUTION TO DE A TODO
CARBONIZED THREAD -- AND IT
COULD PENALIZE ELLIS SEES WITH
CLEANER PORTFOLIOS -- AND REWARD
THOSE WITH MORE GAS IN THEIR
PORTFOLIOS.
SO THE BILL'S SPONSORS SAY THAT
THE PC WOULD LIKELY USE A COST
CAUSATION METHODOLOGY DEVELOP BY
THE CHI SO HOWEVER COUPLE THINGS
ARE IMPORTANT TO NOTE HERE FIRST
THE METHODOLOGY WAS CREATED
PRIOR TO THE EMERGENCE OF MANY
OF THE CCA'S THAT ARE OPERATING
TODAY.
AND SECOND THE PC IS ALREADY
ADDRESSING ARI PROCUREMENT AND
THE R. P. PROCESS -- THEY JUST
RECENTLY PROPOSED DIRECTING THE
LSTS TO PROCURE ARE A VIA THE
NEW PROCUREMENT TRACK -- WITH
THE I. R. P. JUST GETTING TO ITS
FIRST IMPLEMENTATION PHASE IT'S
JUST STARTING THIS IS THE FIRST
TIME IT'S DONE THIS -- WE
BELIEVE IT'S MORE PRUDENT. TO
LET THE PC DO ITS WORK
UNHINDERED BY SPECIAL INTEREST
BILLS -- IN ADDITION THE ARI THE
ART RESOURCE ADEQUACY IS A IN
UNDERGOING A FAIRLY SIGNIFICANT
CHANGE RIGHT NOW WHAT THEY'RE
DOING IS MOVING TO THREE YEAR
FORWARD PROCUREMENT AND THEY'RE
LOOKING AT CENTRALIZED
PROCUREMENT FOR OUR A SO THIS IS
GOING TO BE AN ALREADY
COMPLICATED ISSUE WHEN YOU'VE
GOT SO.
MANY CCA'S IN PLAY IN THE MARKET
RIGHT NOW.
AND THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE THE
PC TO CREATE A NEW FORMULA THAT
ANNUALLY ASSESSES EACH.
EACH LSE WITHIN A THREE YEAR
FORWARD MARKET -- WHICH IS GOING
TO COMPLICATE THINGS BEFORE THE
PROCESS EVEN GET STARTED.
BY ALL APPEARANCES IT SO BY ALL
APPEARANCES BASED ON WHAT CAL WE
IS -- ARGUMENTS HAVE BEEN IN THE
PC HISTORICALLY AND ALSO WHAT
THE WHAT THE EXCUSE ME THE THE
BILL ANALYSIS POINTS OUT.
THIS IT APPEARS OF THIS BILL IS
INTENDED TO INCENT PROCUREMENT.
OF A SPECIFIC SET OF RESOURCES
AND AGAIN THIS IS UNNECESSARY
LITTLE ONE TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT WHY.
FIRST THE I. R. P. IS ALREADY
PROJECTING THAT WE'RE GONNA NEED
TEN GIGAWATTS OF OF NEW
RENEWABLE ENERGY BY.
TWENTY THIRTY THAT'S
CONSERVATIVE BYA LOT OF
ESTIMATES INCLUDING THE IPCC.
AS WE WORK -- TO AS WERE TO THE
CARBON EYES WERE WE'RE SEEING A
NEW ERA WHERE THE GREAT IS GONNA
LOOK VERY DIFFERENT THAN IT
LOOKS TODAY.
AND WE'RE GONNA BE A LOT MORE
POWER ON THE GRID.
THERE ARE MULTIPLE MODELING
EFFORTS UNDERWAY RIGHT NOW AND I
WANT TO POINT TO ONE THAT JUST
CAME OUT THAT THAT GIVES US A
GOOD SNAPSHOT.
CALPINE RECENTLY COMMISSIONED --
E. THREE TO DO AN ANALYSIS OF
LONG RUN ARE A AND WHAT WE NEED
UNDER A LONG -- UNDER THAT LONG
TERM TO CARBONIZATION PATHWAY.
NOW THE ANALYSIS ITSELF WAS
DESIGNED TO IDENTIFY THE ROLE OF
GAS GENERATION BUT WHAT IT
REALLY DID WAS REMIND US OF JUST
HOW DIFFERENT OUR GREAT IS GONNA
LOOK IN TWENTY FIFTY AND HOW
MUCH RENEWABLE ENERGY WE'RE
GONNA NEED BY THEN.
IT ESTIMATES THAT CALIFORNIA
ONLY TO MAX OUT.
IN AN AND THIS IS JUST SO
IMPORTANT IT'S GOING TO MAX OUT
ALL AVAILABLE RESOURCES ALL
AVAILABLE RECENT RENEWABLE
RESOURCES IN CALIFORNIA.
NON SOLAR IT'LL MAX OUT ALL THE
IN STATE WHEN IT'S GOING TO MAX
OUT AT A STATE WIND ALL
GEOTHERMAL ALL BIOMASS.
EVERYTHING WE CAN FIND.
EVEN ON TOP OF THAT IT ESTIMATES
WERE GONNA NEED FIFTY FIVE
THOUSAND MEGAWATTS OF SOLAR BY.
TWENTY FORTY EIGHTY NINE
THOUSAND MEGAWATTS OF SOLAR BY
[inaudible]
TWENTY FIFTY CONSERVATIVELY.
AND AGAIN SOLAR IS UNIQUE
BECAUSE IT CAN BE CITED
VIRTUALLY ANYWHERE TO PRODUCE
POWER AND SO IT'S ANTICIPATED TO
FILL IN.
AFTER WE BASICALLY OPTIMIZED
EVERYTHING WE HAVE.
THE TRUTH IS WE DON'T NEED
ENHANCED ARE A RULES. TO INCENT
PROCUREMENT OR OTHERWISE
CONVINCE THE LSE'S TO PROCURE IN
A CERTAIN WAY PRETTY SOON
CALIFORNIA'S GONNA BE BUYING
ABSOLUTELY EVERYTHING WE HAVE
IT'S GOING TO NEED.
TO THE OTHER THING THAT WE'RE
LEARNING IS THAT -- SOLAR AND
WIND.
WE'RE WE'RE LEARNING MORE ABOUT
SOLAR AND WIND OVER BUILDING
CURTAILMENT.
THERE ARE SOME NEW STUDIES ABOUT
THIS AS WELL -- THERE ARE MAJOR
COST BENEFITS THAT ARE MERGING
TO THE OVERBILLED OF BOTH SOLAR
AND WIND SO PATH TOWARDS THE
CARBONIZATION.
AND IT'S FULLY UNDERSTANDING
THAT YES CURTAILMENT WILL GROW
BUT THE CURTAILMENT IS A TOOL
IT'S NOT A PROBLEM.
AND IT'S THANKS IN PART TO HELLO
ACOSTA RESOURCES ARE EVEN THE
CAL PLAN REPORT SHOWS THAT WE
COULD SEE TEN TO TWENTY OR
10212% CURTAILMENT AND STILL
ECONOMICAL FROM THE REPAIR
PERSPECTIVE.
SO I TALK ABOUT THE STUDIES AS A
WAY TO HELP US ALL UNDERSTAND
THAT THAT WE'RE ONLY JUST NOW
BEGINNING TO UNDERSTAND WHAT A
FULLY DE CARBONIZED GREAT IT'S
GOING TO BE LOOKING LIKE WE JUST
DON'T KNOW XACTLY WHAT THE WHAT
THE KEY PIECES ARE.
WE'RE BOTH WITNESSED AND
PARTICIPANTS IN A VERY FLUID OF
MARKET EVOLUTION.
SO WE NEED TO KEEP OUR EYE ON
THE BALL BECAUSE THERE'S A
THERE'S A LOT HAPPENING RIGHT
NOW.
RATHER THAN DEVOTING THE LIMITED
STATE STAFFING RESOURCES TO
CREATING BOUTIQUE ARE A FORMULAS
FOR DIFFERENT HELICES BASED ON
AN OLD GRAD MODEL.
LET'S INSTEAD WITH THE PC FOCUS
ON THE TASK AT HAND.
WILDFIRE LIABILITY UTILITY
SAFETY PROTOCOLS UTILITY
SOLVENCY AND LOW SHIFTING
MECHANICS.
ONCE WE GET A HANDLE ON THAT
WHAT WE REALLY NEED TO DO IS
START PROCURING AS MUCH
RENEWABLE ENERGY AS POSSIBLE AS
FAST AS POSSIBLE.
THE WELL INTENDED WE DO
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS A WELL
INTENDED BILL IT DOES NOT HELP
WITH ANY OF OUR PRESENT OR
FUTURE CHALLENGES WE BELIEVE WE
BELIEVE IT'S GOING TO DISTRACT
IF YOU SEE STAFF DISRUPT THE
PROCUREMENT PROCESS AND WE
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOU TO OPPOSE
THE BILL [inaudible]
THANKS.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TONY HUNTER
ON BEHALF OF THE SOLAR ENERGY
INDUSTRIES ASSOCIATION OR
ASSOCIATE MY COMMENTS WITH THOSE
OF SAN ANDY AT LSA.
AND FURTHER ITERATE AGAIN THE
BILL IS NOT NECESSARY WE SEE
THIS INSTRUCTION WE ASK FOR NO
VOTE [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
OUR MEMBERS.
DID YOU WANNA RESPOND
[inaudible]
TO SURE.
ARM FIRST OF ALL THIS IS A
MARKET SOLUTION SO ONCE IT'S IN
PLACE IT REQUIRES -- NO
ATTENTION BY THE P. YOU SEE.
THE BILL IS TECH NEUTRAL EFFECT
IF.
LOAD SERVING AND HE WANTS TO
HAVE LOTS AND LOTS OF SOLAR AND
STORAGE.
AND THAT WORKS THAT'S JUST FINE
THERE'S NOTHING IN HERE THAT
TALKS ABOUT TECHNOLOGY -- I WILL
POINT OUT THAT THE NEWEST --
PLAYERS IN THIS AREA THE CAL
CCA'S THAT THEIR ASSOCIATIONS
NEUTRAL ON THE BELL.
ARE THEN I'M GOING TO DISAGREE
RESPECTFULLY WITH THE OPPOSITION
IN THEIR STATEMENT.
THAT -- THE CPUC HAS REJECTED
OUR THIS APPROACH.
OUR FIRST OF ALL.
THE BILL WOULD ONLY DIRECT THE
SHIP CPUS SHE'D ALLOCATE ANY ANY.
INTEGRATION RESOURCE OBLIGATIONS
THAT THEY ESTABLISH OUR SUCH AS
FLEXIBLE RESOURCE.
ADEQUACY -- WAIT A SECOND THIS
IS THE WRONG SECTION.
WELL THE POINT IS THAT THE CPUC
HAS NEVER REJECTED THIS APPROACH
AND IN FACT THEY'VE SAID THAT
IT'S A PREFERRED APPROACH.
ARE THEY JUST HAVE NOT --
DECIDED TO NOT TAKE THIS
APPROACH YET.
WE'RE GOING TO ASK HIM TO MAKE
THAT A PRIORITY SO WE WILL GET
THE APPROPRIATE.
MODELS HE'S ME THE APPROPRIATE
MARKET SIGNAL WHICH WILL BE A
VERY EFFICIENT WAY TO MAKE SURE
THAT PEOPLE HAVE BALLOTS
PORTFOLIOS AGAIN THAT COULD BE
DONE.
EASILY WITH OVER BUILDING SOLAR
AND HAVING STORAGE WHATEVER
APPROACH WILL BE JUST FINE.
VERY WELL A MEMBERS [inaudible]
CENTER STERN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND THANK
YOU SIMILAR FOR ENGAGING ON THE
ISSUE I KNOW WE'VE BEEN.
CONCERNED ABOUT THE DUCK CURVE
FOR MANY YEARS AND THE IMPACT
IT'S HAD.
BUT I JUST.
I READ THESE RECENT REPORTS SOME
OF THE ONES YOU CITED IN.
I'M STRUGGLING WITH THE WHOLE
PREMISE OF OVER BUILDING BEING A
PROBLEM BECAUSE IT'S NOT.
RIGHT AND SO THE QUESTION FOR
YOU IS HOW.
IF CURTAILMENT ENDS UP BEING A
COST EFFECTIVE SOLUTION FOR THE
FUTURE OF THE GRID.
AND WHAT I I WAS JUST READING
CLEAN POWER RESEARCH I THINK AT
A RECENT STUDY.
AND THERE WERE A FEW OTHERS
MENTIONED I THINK YOU.
THREE BUT TO SAY THAT.
IT'S ACTUALLY CHEAPER TO OVER
GENERATE SOLAR -- AT PEAK HOURS
AND AND CURTAIL WHEN NEEDED
VERSES -- UNDER BUILDING AND
THEN TRYING TO MEET THAT WITH
OTHER BIG INFRASTRUCTURE -- OR
FIND I NEED TO GET YOUR TAKE ON
AS RHEINISCHE COMPLETE AGREEMENT
THAT.
IF OVER BUILDING IS THE RIGHT
WAY TO GO.
AS LONG AS YOU HAVE RESOURCES OF
TIME WHEN THE SUN IS NOT UP.
I'M FINE WITH THAT YOU CAN YOU
CAN BUILD.
AS MUCH SOLAR AS YOU WANT.
YOU JUST HAVE TO BE ABLE TO
SERVE THE LOAD WHEN THE SUN GOES
DOWN AND MAKE SURE THAT WE DON'T
GO TO THE I. SL WHICH THEN WOULD.
WOULD LIKELY PURCHASE NATURAL
GAS BACK UP.
PROBABLY FROM OUT OF STATE
PERHAPS EVEN CALL AND THAT'S
WHAT WE WANT TO PREVENT.
AND SO FUNCTIONAL BECAUSE THIS
IS A SHALL WRITE THIS THIS
DOESN'T GIVE THEM ANY DISCRETION.
TO ADOPT THIS FRAMEWORK THIS IS
A SO IT DOESN'T ACTUALLY BUT IT
SAYS IS THAT THEY SHOULD ADOPT
THE METHODOLOGY WE DON'T SAY
EXACTLY WHAT THAT IS OTHER THAN
THAT HE'S TRIBUNE YET.
ACCORDING -- TO PEOPLE'S DEMANDS
FOR THAT POWER SAID THAT THOSE
WHO PAY. TO GO ON TO THE SPOT
MARKET GET THOSE HIGHER PRICES
POTENTIALLY EVEN FROM COAL THAT
THOSE PEOPLE PAY THE PRICE.
SO WHATEVER LOAD SERVING ENERGY
THAT IS THIS IS A MARKET SIGNAL.
BUT BY THE WAY IT SHOULD BE A
SMALL FRACTION OF THE TOTAL
ENERGY.
SHARE A MY EXPERT NAY LIKE AT A
POINT JUST ON THE POINT OF
CURTAILMENT THIS DOESN'T THIS
DOESN'T ADDRESS -- ANY IT
DOESN'T SAY YOU CANNOT CURTAIL
WHEN ITIS ECONOMIC TO CURTAIL
WHAT IT SAYS IS IF THE P. YOU
SEE IN THE R. P. PROCESS.
DETERMINES THAT IT IS OVERALL
ECONOMIC TO SAY BUILD A PUMP
STORAGE FACILITY TO COLLECT THAT
LOST ENERGY BECAUSE NOW WE'RE-LOSING SO MUCH THAT IT IS WORTH
WHILE. TO TO BUILD A PUMP
STORAGE FACILITY.
THAT THAT FACILITY BE PAID --
FOR BY EIGHT LSE IS ON THE BASIS
OF THAT THEY ARE USING IT SO IF
YOU'RE IF YOU IF YOU HAVE A VERY
IN BALANCED PORTFOLIO THAT IS
CAUSED A NEED FOR THAT.
STORAGE YOU PAY MORE THAN
SOMEBODY FOR EXAMPLE PENINSULA
CLEAN ENERGY HAS A GOAL OF
MATCHING THEIR RESOURCES THEIR
SUPPLY IN THEIR DEMAND THEY HAVE
AS PART OF THEIR RB GOALS.
A GOAL OF MATCHING SUPPLY AND
DEMAND YOU WILL PAY A LOT LESS
FOR THAT PURPOSE STORAGE SO IT
ENCOURAGES ELLIS CEASE. TO TO
CREATE BELLS PORTFOLIOS THAT
MATCH THEIR LOADS.
LET ME JUST SAY HOMES THAT WERE
ENCOURAGE BALANCING PORTFOLIOS
THIS IS NEUTRAL.
SHE GAVE A PARTICULAR EXAMPLE --
IF THERE WERE ACCESS.
STORAGE THE POINT IS YOU DON'T
WANT TO GO TO THE SPOT MARKET
YOU WANT TO HAVE LONG TERM
CONTRACTS.
WHICH ALLOW YOU WHEN.
YOUR PARTICULAR RENEWABLES ARE
NOT AVAILABLE TO GO.
THAT ALLOW YOU TO GO TO
ALTERNATIVE.
I DON'T KNOW OR CARE WHAT THAT
ALTERNATIVE IS BUT I THINK THAT
SHOULD BE UNDER LONG TERM
CONTRACT THOUGH THEY'LL BE
OCCASIONS NO MATTER WHAT YOU DO
WHEN YOU PROBABLY HAVE TO GO TO
THE STEP SPOT MARKET.
THE POINTED THIS BILL IS TO
AVOID THOSE CHARGES WHICH
CURRENTLY ARE JUST DISTRIBUTED
ON THE BASIS OF LOAD WE WANT TO
HAVE THEM DISTRIBUTED ON THE
BASIS.
OF OUR WHOEVER USE THE RESOURCE.
AND SO IT FOR FOR THE OPPONENTS.
YOU'RE SAYING YOU'RE WORRIED
ABOUT YOUR LOCKING IN. ONE VIEW
OF THE GREAT BUT THEY'RE ARGUING
THIS ACTUALLY STILL ALLOWS.
FOR FLEXIBILITY SO.
IS IS THE CONCERN ABOUT --
AILING CURTAILMENT OR IS THAT
WHAT WERE THAT SORT OF FUTURE OF
OF A COST EFFECTIVE OVER
JANUARY'S IT'S IS IT SOME OTHER
ISSUE THAT SORT OF DRIVING THE
THE CONCERN ABOUT THIS FRAMEWORK.
DID I GET THAT DID I GET THAT
WRONG I MEAN IT IT'S YEAH NO I I
MEAN.
PART OF PART OF WHAT WE NEED TO
UNDERSTAND IS A PRETTY
COMPLICATED ISSUE AND AND BY AT
AN END AGAIN.
KELLY HAS PROPOSED DOING THIS AT
THE PC MULTIPLE TIMES THE PC HAS
DECIDED IT'S NOT IN THE INTEREST
OF THE PARTIES TO DO THIS.
I MEAN IF WE STEP BACK AND LOOK
AT THE FACT THAT THEY ARE A
PROGRAM RIGHT NOW IS BEING IS
BEING FAIRLY OVERHAULED THEY'RE
pAPPROACH AND IT AND I THINK
THERE'S A THERE'S A REASON FOR
THAT.
WHAT WHAT IS THAT?
IN YOUR MIND BECAUSE I THINK
THERE'S SO MUCH FLUIDITY THAT'S
HAPPENING IN THE MARKET RIGHT
NOW THAT THESE KINDS OF THINGS
ARE GOING TO BE RESOLVED ON
THEIR OWN.
THIS IS A REALLY COMPLICATED I
MEAN AGAIN WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
FACT WE GOT FORTY ELLIS SEES
THAT ARE IN THE MARKET WE'RE NOT
GONNA HAVE ASK THE P. YOU SEE
FORCED THE PC. TO BREAK DOWN
EACH LSE'S.
BASICALLY EACH LSE'S ANNUAL LOAD
AND PORTFOLIO.
ON AN ANNUAL BASIS WITHIN A
THREE YEAR FORWARD FORWARD ARE A
MARKET I DON'T KNOW HOW THEY'RE
GOING T DO THAT I DON'T KNOW IF
THE PC KNOWS HOW THEY'RE GOING
TO DO THAT.
WHAT WE DO KNOW IS THAT THE PC
HAS THIS AUTHORITY ALREADY THEY
WOULD HAVE USED IT IF THEY
THOUGHT THEY WANTED?
TO AND THEY'RE ALREADY DIRECTING
THE PARTIES RIGHT NOW AT LEAST
BASED ON THE PROPOSED -- RULING
THAT CAME OUT A COUPLE WEEKS AGO.
THERE DIRECTING THE ELLIS USED
TO PROCURE ARE A RESOURCES RIGHT
NOW.
AND SO THE PC'S ALREADY HANDLING
THIS IT'S ALREADY ADDRESSING
THIS.
I'D RATHER NOT HAMSTRING THE P.
YOU SEE WITH A SPECIFIC
METHODOLOGY WRECKED OF TO DO A
METHODOLOGY -- RIGHT WHEN IT'S
BEGINNING TO GET SOME ESCAPE%
VELOCITY ON THE IRP PROCESS AND
THE ARE A PROCESS AND ESPECIALLY
WHEN WE'RE LEARNING SO MUCH
ABOUT THE GREAT CAPABILITIES OF
SOLAR AND WIND AND STORAGE AND
EVERYTHING ELSE.
IS IT FAIR TO SAY THAT JUST TO
MAKE SURE I KNOW WHAT I'M VOTING
ON HERE THAT.
IT'S IT'S SHALL DEVELOP
[inaudible]
SO THE IT WOULD THEY STILL HAVE
THE DISCRETION TO NOT USE AYE I
GET THE STAFF TIME CONCERN BUT
CAN THEY STILL SAY NO TO THIS
METHODOLOGY.
IN IN YOUR MIND IS THAT THE
INTENT TO MAKE THIS A DISORDER.
A DISCRETIONARY METHODOLOGY
COULD USE OR IS IT OR IS IT YOU
WANT TO SEE IT LOOKS THIS WAY
GOING FORWARD THAT SAID IS THAT
WHAT'S GOING TO BE THIS BILL
PROPOSES A PRINCIPLE. TO BE USED
IN DEVELOPING A METHODOLOGY SO
IT DOES NOT.
PRESCRIBE A PARTICULAR
METHODOLOGY IT SAYS.
THE METHODOLOGY THAT YOU CHOOSE
HAS TO BILL PEOPLE BASED ON HOW
MUCH OF THE INTEGRATION RESOURCE
THEY ARE USING IT HAS TO BE
CAUSATION BASED.
ALLOCATIONS WERE NOT GONNA
SPREAD OUT BY LOW CHAIR WE'RE
GONNA SPREAD IT BY HOW MUCH YOU
ARE USING.
THE SYSTEM INTEGRATION RESOURCES
THAT.
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT SO IT'S
REALLY A VERY SIMPLE THING IS
REALLY NOT A COMPLICATED THING.
RIGHT NOW -- WIND BIOMASS
GEOTHERMAL WE DON'T WE DON'T WE
DON'T GET ME CREDIT THAT WE'RE
NOT CAUSING THE DUCK NECK
PROBLEM -- THIS BILL WOULD
FRANKLY GIVE US YOU KNOW A
LITTLE BIT MORE OF A LEVEL
PLAYING FIELD BY REQUIRING.
THOSE WHO ARE PURCHASING SOLAR
ALSO TO PAY FOR DUCK NECK COSTS
UNDER STAND.
I GUESS THOUGH THAT WAS MY POINT
TO YOUR INTENT IS FOR THIS TO BE
ADOPTED AND UTILIZED YOU YOU
WANT THAT IS.
THE PRINCIPAL BUT IT'S NOT A
PARTICULAR METHODOLOGY NEVER AYE
SO DOES HAVE A PARTICULAR
METHODOLOGY THAT IT NOW USES. TO
ALLOCATE OF FLEXIBLE RAMPING
COSTS AMONG LOCAL REGULATORY
AUTHORITIES SO BETWEEN THE P.
YOU SEE AND A PUBLICLY OWNED
UTILITIES THIS WILL JUST TAKE
THIS DOWN TO THE ELLIS THE
LEVELS IT'S ALREADY BEING DONE I
JUST WANTED TO ASK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER.
I MEAN ARE YOU OPEN AT ALL AND I
DON'T.
I'D BE MORE COMFORTABLE WITH THE
WITH THE SHALL CONSIDER KIND OF
FRAMEWORK AS OPPOSED -- TO USE A
METHODOLOGY BUT I THAT WOULD
TAKE.
A PRECEDING THAT WOULD IN FACT.
OUR DISTRACT THE P. YOU SEE FROM
WHAT IT HAS TO DO WITH THE POINT
HERE IS INSTEAD OF DOING A TWO
OR THREE OR FOUR YEAR PROCEEDING
TO DETERMINE.
WHETHER OR NOT YOU WOULD USE
THIS METHODOLOGY -- WE WOULD
CALLUM USES METHODOLOGY NOW THEY
ALREADY WILL HAVE ALL THE
INFORMATION THEY NEED BECAUSE
THE I SO TELLS THEM EXACTLY.
WHAT COSTS WERE INCURRED BY BOTH
AND IT BY AT ALL THE ENTITIES?
THE OTHER THING IS IT MAY BE
THAT WIND OR FEW THERMAL OR
WHATEVER LIKES THIS BILL.
I DON'T REALLY CARE WHETHER THEY
LIKE IT OR NOT NICE TO BE MY
SPONSOR BUT I DON'T CARE.
ABOUT WHAT I CARE ABOUT IS THAT
BECAUSE THE MARKET SIGNALS WORK
AND THAT WE MAKE THE P. UC'S
WORK EASIER WHICH IS WHAT THIS
WOULD DO.
THEY WON'T HAVE TO DO A LONG
PROCEEDING LET ME ALSO READ FOR
A QUOTE FROM THIS -- THE P. UC --
HAS REJECTED PARTY'S ARGUMENTS
THAT THE COPY SO CAUSATION
METHODOLOGY IS COUNTER TO
CALIFORNIA'S GOLD RENEWABLES.
THE P. YOU SEE HAS STATED WE
BELIEVE THE OPPOSITE IS TRUE IN
PARTICULAR WE NOTE.
THAT SEVERAL OF THE BENEFITS
DESCRIBED BY THE LEGISLATURE AS
JUSTIFICATION FOR THE R. P. AS
PROGRAM.
OUR BEST SUPPORTED BY INCENTIVES
TO MINIMIZE RENEWABLE
INTEGRATION COSTS SUCH AS
ADDITIONAL FLEXIBILITY.
pSAYING IS DON'T GO TO THE SPOT
MARKET UNLESS YOU HAVE TO WHICH
WILL HAPPEN FROM TIME TO TIME.
BUT MINIMIZE THE NUMBER OF TIMES
YOU HAVE TO GO BECAUSE IF YOU
HAVE LONG TERM CONTRACTS WHICH
IS SURE THAT RELIABILITY.
YOU'RE GOING TO BE MUCH BETTER
OFF COST TWICE AND AGAIN I AM
COMPLETELY TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL.
THANK YOU FOR THE INTELLIGENCE
BUDGET A RESPONSE THERE IT JUST
YOU DO NOT WANT TO SEE THIS KIND
OF METHODOLOGY ADOPT ISN'T WHAT
WHAT'S THE ALTERNATIVE THAT YOU
ALL WANT TO SEE IN AN LSA OR
THAT FUTURE.
YOU LIKE WHAT YOU LIKE BUSINESS
AS USUAL RIGHT NOW IS THAT IS
THAT THE POOR I MEAN THAT THE
CURRENT ALLOCATION FORM THAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT IS THAT
SEEM MORE EQUITABLE OR JUST A
QUICK RESPONSE AND THEN ALL.
OF BACK BACK OUT HERE THANK YOU.
I THINK BUSINESS AS USUAL IS IN
FLUX RIGHT NOW BEEN RIGHT NOW
BUSINESS AS USUAL IS CHANGING
AND SO WE DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT
THE NEW ARE RE RULES ARE GOING
TO BE WE DON'T KNOW.
WHAT THE WHAT THE RESPONSE FROM
THE PARTIES WILL BE FROM THE P.
UC'S LATEST DIRECTIVE THAT AGAIN
WAS JUST TWO WEEKS AGO TO DIRECT
THE LSE'S TO GO PROCURE ARE A --
IN OUR SINCE THIS IS.
THIS IS BOTH PREMATURE AND ITS
PREJUDICES AGAINST SOLAR AND
NANCY WAS TALKING A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THAT AND THAT IT IT GIVES
A LEGUP TO WIND BIOMASS
GEOTHERMAL.
MY POINT IS BASED ON THE NEED TO
DE CARBONIZED ARE GRADED IN THE
TIME PERIOD WE HAVE WHAT WE NEED
TO BUY ALL THE GEOTHERMAL ALL
THE WIND ALL THE BIO MASS THAT
WE CAN GET OUR HANDS ON AND WE
WILL.
IN ADDITION TO THAT WE'RE GOING
TO BUY A WHOLE BUNCH OF SOLAR.
SO WE NEED TO MOVE OUT OF OUR
PAST RUBRIC OF OF SCARCITY
THINKING AND SEILING OUR
PROCUREMENT UNDERSTAND THAT WE
GOT A BY ALL OF IT WE'RE GONNA
MEET OUR CLIMATE TOWARD ITS AND
WE NEED NOT PREJUDICED AGAINST
ANYTHING.
WE NEED TO START WORKING
TOGETHER.
AND I WOULD ACTUALLY AGREE THAT.
THAT'S THE CASE AND THAT THIS
BILL HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH THAT
IT'S SIMPLY GIVING A MARKET
SIGNAL.
AND I'M HAPPY A FEW.
THE TO HAVE ALL THE SO IF YOU
COULD CURE ALL THE SOLO YOU WANT
CENTER BRADFORD.
THANK YOU I WANTED THINK -- SOON
IN COURT FOR A COMMONSENSE
MEASURE HERE.
THIS IS COMPLICATED AND
CONVOLUTED BECAUSE WE'VE HAD
LEGISLATORS FOR THE LAST TWENTY
YEARS.
RIGHT ENERGY POLICY AND THEY
KNOW NOTHING ABOUT ENERGY AND
THAT'S WHY WE ARE DEALING WITH
THIS HODGE PODGE OF WHAT WE CALL.
ENERGY RELIABILITY THE NUMBER
ONE ISSUE FOR THE P. YOU SEE IS
NOT PRICE IS NOT NOT TECHNOLOGY
ITS RELIABILITY AND THIS IS WHAT
THIS BILL IS IT'S A RELIABILITY
ISSUE WE WERE ANY ENERGY CRISIS
IN.
TWO THOUSAND TWO THOUSAND ONE
BECAUSE OF THE SPOT MARKET
BECAUSE OF NOT HAVING --
ADEQUATE RESOURCE IN HAND TO BUY
IT ON THE SPOT MARKET WE WILL
NEVER EXIST AS A STATE WILL
NEVER BE THEN -- Là A FOURTH
LEADING ECONOMY IN THE WORLD IF
WE THINK WE SAIL MORE SOLAR.
WE PAY I SHOULD SAY.
A LITTLE NEVADA THE TAKE MORE
SOLAR THEN WE USE IN CALIFORNIA
ON A DAILY BASIS AND WE CONTINUE
TO TALK ABOUT BUILDING MORE
SOLAR BUT DOCTOR QUIRK WILL KNOW
THERE'S NOT A SINGLE SOLAR
ELECTRON CAN MOVE.
WITHOUT TRADITIONAL GENERATION
YOU NEED TURBINE YOU NEED TO
NURTURE SO TO CONTINUE TO SAY
WE'RE GOING TO DO AWAY WITH BASS
LOW POWER.
WILL THEN WE WILL BE.
IN A WORLD OF TROUBLE I AS FAR
SYSTEM RELIABILITY THIS IS THE
SYSTEM RELIABILITY BUT BILL IT'S
COMMON SENSE IF WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THE LIGHTS STAY ON AND SO I
MOVED THE MEASURE.
VERY WELL WE HAVE A MOTION --
CLERK A DID YOU WANNA MAKE ANY
CLOSING COMMENTS -- JUST TO SAY
THIS IS TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL.
IF PEOPLE WANT TO BUY A LOT OF
SOLAR AND LOT OF STORAGE THAT'S
JUST FINE WITH ME.
IT'S MERELY SENDING A PRICE
SIGNAL IF YOU HAVE TO GO ON TO
THE SPOT MARKET.
HOWEVER YOU'LL AVOID GOING ON TO
THE SPOT MARKET IS JUST FINE FOR
ME THANK YOU THANK YOU.
CLICK THIS CALL THE ROLL.
THE PASS IS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WESO I WAS SO I
MORE LOCK BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I CHIANG DODD.
HERTZBERG HILL HILL AYE MCGUIRE
MCGUIRE AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SKINNER STERN.
STONE STONE AYE WIENER WIENER
AYE.
THE BILL HAS ENOUGH VOTES SO
WILL.
LEAVE THEIR OPEN FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA.
NOW -- GO OVER OUR VOLUME LIFT
THE THE CALL ON THE REMAINING
BILLS -- STRICKEN IN WITH ITEM
NUMBER ONE EIGHTY FIVE TWENTY
THREE QUIRK PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
HE PASSES AMENDED JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE SIX ZERO
MORE LOCK CHIANG HERTZBERG
MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE SKINNER STONE.
WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
WE'LL GIVE THE ROLE OF THE PRESS
OF MEMBERS ITEM NUMBER TWO AB
SIX SIXTY QUICK PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THE PASSES AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTE
[inaudible]
THREE THREE BRADFORD
CHANGE [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
WIENER HI.
LOOK AT THE ROLE PROGRESSIVE
MEMBERS ITEM NUMBER.
THREE EIGHTY NINE ELEVEN DO YOU
PASSED TO JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
CURRENT VOTE SIX ZERO MOORLACH
[inaudible]
OKAY.
AT BRADFORD BRADFORD I'D CHIANG
HERTZBERG MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE SKINNER [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
HI.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR A. B. TEN
TWENTY EIGHT CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. TO PASTOR PREPARATIONS
CURRENT VOTE SIX ZERO MOORLACH
[inaudible]
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD NO I MEAN SORRY SORRY
MOORLACH NO BRADFORD AYE CHANGE.
HERTZBERG.
MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
I NUMBER FIVE A. B. -- TEN
SEVENTY ACTUALLY THE CONSENT
CALENDAR CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR --
MOORLACH.
MORE LIKE I CHANGE [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
SKINNER RIGHT SKINNER AYE WIENER --
I ITEM NUMBER SIX AB ELEVEN
FORTY TO CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
AB ELEVEN FORTY TO DO PASSED TO
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE
FIVE ONE MOORLACH.
MORE LIKE NO CHIANG [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
MCGUIRE.
I SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE STERN.
WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
AB I'LL THIRTEEN SIXTY TWO BY
O'DONNELL I REMEMBER SEVEN CLERK
PLEASE CALL.
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
CURRENT VOTE SEVEN ZERO MORE
LOCKED.
MORE LIKE I CHIANG HERTZBERG.
MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE SKINNER.
HI SKINNER AYE HERTZBERG AYE
WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB FIFTEEN
THIRTEEN BY SOMEONE NUMBER HOLD
ON THE CALL.
THAT WAS ACTUALLY ON THE CONSENT.
EIGHT ITEM NUMBER NINE A. B.
FIFTEEN EIGHTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK.
AB FIFTEEN EIGHTY FOUR DAY
PASSES AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
CURRENT VOTE SEVEN ZERO MORE
LOCK.
MORE LIKE I CHIANG DIED
[inaudible]
HERTZBERG. FIVE HERTZBERG AYE.
INNER SKINNER AYE STERN
[inaudible]
STERN AYE [inaudible]
IN A WELCOME BACK TO ITEM NUMBER
ONE AB FIVE TWENTY THREE QUIRK
PLEASE CALL THE OFFICE MEMBERS.
MOORLACH CHANGE.
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG AYE SKINNER
SKINNER AYE.
ITEM NUMBER TWO EIGHTY SIX SIXTY
QUIRK PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
BRADFORD CHIANG.
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
RUBIO.
SKINNER.
SKINNER I ITEM NUMBER THREE A.
B. NINE ELEVEN FISCALLY UPS
MEMBERS.
MOORLACH CHAIN HERTZBERG. NINE
LINE NUMBER THREE NINE OF NINE
ONE HERTZBERG.
AYE SKINNER.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR EIGHT THE TEN
TWENTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GONZALEZ.
EASY I HEAR LISTEN JOHN.
CLICK PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS HERTZBERG. TEN TWENTY
EIGHT GONZALEZ GONZALEZ.
SALAS AYE I MEAN HERTZBERG AYE.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR AND SAT
DOWN.
CLICK PLEASE CALL TO MEMBERS.
HERTZBERG HI HERTZBERG AYE.
ON ITEM SIX ELEVEN FORTY TWO
FRIEDMAN PAUL POPS OF MEMBERS.
HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE STERN.
SO WHICH ONE IS THIS.
NUMBER.
ELEVEN ELEVEN FORTY TWO YEAH.
NUMBER SEVEN A. B. THIRTEEN
SIXTY TWO BY A DONALD CLERK
PLEASE CALL TO MEMBERS
[inaudible]
THAT MEANS.
EVANS OUT.
A NUMBER NINE BY.
FOUR PLEASE CLUB TO MEMBERS.
MMHM THAT ONE'S.
CHEN IS ABSENT IN DODD.
WELL OKAY THEN WE WILL.
AND DID WE DID -- HERTZBERG GET
ON NUMBER.
ONE NUMBER.
TWO BUT I WILL [inaudible]
THIRTY TWO ON NUMBER TWO DID YOU
WANNA GO FOR IT YEAH.
OKAY CLICK PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AB SIX SIXTY
HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE.
THEY WERE GONNA CLOSE ROLE NOW.
BILLS ARE OUT.
OKAY HAVE A NICE TO EVERYBODY WE
ARE NOW FORMALLY ADJOURNED
[inaudible]
WHAT WEBSITE [inaudible]
YES